moins affectés par le virus de lakovic
19 ils subissent de plein fouet la crise
économique qui en découlent nombre
d'entre eux sont concernés par des
statuts précaires qui ne leur procurent
pas la protection sociale d'autres se
retrouvent coupés de tout moyen d'accès
à l'éducation
il est indispensable que nous
établissons des dispositions spécifiques
afin d'éviter que nos jeunes ne se
retrouve enfermé durablement dans le
piège de la pauvreté
monsieur le président si les nouvelles
technologies ont largement participé au
développement de nos sociétés
elle contribue malheureusement à l'essor
d'un nouveau contexte d'insécurité
ces derniers mois ont formidablement
accélérer la transition numérique
mais ces progrès se sont accompagnés
également une explosion des
cyberattaques le cyberespace est
désormais une zone d'affrontements à
part entière au même titre que la terre
la mer et le ciel
que devient la souveraineté à l'heure du
numérique
quand la sécurité le droit l'économie la
fiscalité et la monnaie sont remises en
cause
il convient à mon sens de s'entendre sur
des règles communes afin dé dicter des
mesures d'encadrement et de bonne
conduite
ce n'est pas seulement la garantie d'un
meilleur fonctionnement de nos
institutions
c'est aussi l'assurance de préserver la
souveraineté des états et les libertés
individuelles
en même temps la vague de désinformation
s'est intensifiée notamment au travers
des réseaux sociaux ces derniers mois
nos sociétés sont vulnérables à ces
manoeuvres
aussi je salue la campagne de
sensibilisation lancée par les nations
unies afin de lutter contre l info démis
monaco a entrepris de se doter de
compétences numériques forte pour d'une
part capté les nombreuses opportunités
qu'offre le numérique en matière
économique et environnemental et d'autre
part s'assurer d'un développement
durable et respectueux des personnes
ainsi le modèle numérique responsable et
durable que j'ai voulu pour mon pays sa
compagne non seulement d'investissements
importants en infrastructures formation
et aides aux entreprises mais également
de l'édiction de règles législatives sur
le président on ne peut aborder ce
nouveau contexte d'insécurité sans
évoquer la gravité de la crise
climatique
les catastrophes naturelles de grande
ampleur vont s'intensifier et
provoqueront nous le savons des
situations humanitaires d'urgence les
déplacements de populations des
catastrophes auront un impact sur
l'accès aux ressources naturelles
ces phénomènes sont des vecteurs
d'instabilité politiques et de conflits
la pandémie actuelle a démontré à quel
point nous sommes vulnérables
lorsque nous détruisons les écosystèmes
planétaires scientifiques sont clairs à
ce sujet nous devons nous attendre à un
risque accru d'épidémie de ce genre si
nous nous changeons pas nos
comportements le ralentissement de nos
activités imposées par la pandémie n'a
pas infléchi la courbe de la hausse des
températures
ni réduit la destruction de la nature
aussi les reports des grands rendez-vous
environnementaux ne signifie pas une
suspension sine aidiez de nos
engagements mais appelle bien au
contraire au doublement de nos efforts
l'urgence est toujours là est plus que
jamais une mobilisation de tous est
nécessaire
à ce titre je tiens à saluer
l'initiative de secrétaire général de
convoquer un sommet sur la biodiversité
lui accordant ainsi sa juste place au
coeur de notre agenda politique la
décision collective de le maintenir le
30 septembre prochain
en dépit du contexte sanitaire confirme
cet engagement auquel je souscris
pleinement
monaco est et demeure résolument engagés
pour la protection de l'environnement et
le développement durable
que ce soit pour suivant la transition
énergétique en accélérant le
développement de la mobilité douce en
faisant la promotion de l'économie
circulaire
la principauté a placé l'évolution des
modes de consommation de production au
coeur de son projet de société
chaque volet de l'action du gouvernement
monégasque doit s'inscrire dans les
exigences d'un développement durable
telle est la ligne que lui est fixé dès
monsieur le président alors que la crise
actuelle a focalisé une grande partie de
l'attention mondiale sur les chiffres de
la croissance et sur la relance de
l'économie
il ya un risque important que nous nous
détournions des autres piliers du
développement durable
aussi est-il fondamental de saisir
l'opportunité qui nous est offerte de
repenser nos modèles économiques et
sociaux
s'appuyant sur des principes respectueux
de l'environnement plus que jamais la
feuille de route que nous avons établies
en 2015 doit nous guider dans cette
période de grande incertitude
plus que jamais la pandémie de lakovic
19 démontre qu'il est crucial
d'atteindre les objectifs définis par le
programme de développement à l'horizon
2030 la cour de paris sur le changement
climatique et le programme d'action
d'addis abeba pour ce faire un surcroît
d'ambition et de mobilisation est
nécessaire non seulement pour vaincre la
commis 19 mais aussi pour adapter nos
instruments de coopération multilatérale
la période de distanciation social que
nous vivons doivent faire résonner en
nous les mots ne laisser personne de
côté
nous avons mis au coeur des eaux d'aidé
et sur lesquels s'ouvre le préambule de
la charte des nations unies nous peuples
des nations unies afin d'accroître notre
solidarité
je vous remercie de votre attention au
nom de l'assemblée plein sauf monakoff
au nom de l'assemblée générale jeu s'est
renversé le souverain de monaco de
l'allocution qu'il doit me prononcer je
donne maintenant la parole au
représentant du yémen afin qu'il
présente une allocation d'une allocution
par le chef d'état c'est drôle madame la
présidente
excellences mesdames et messieurs j'ai
l'honneur de présenter monsieur abd
rabbo mansour hadi mansour président de
la république du yémen pour s'adresser à
la soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
cela ira au nom de dieu clément et
miséricordieux
monsieur le président de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies majesté
altesse excellence je voudrais à long
terme de mon propos exprimé mes
chaleureuses félicitations au président
de la soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale
je lui souhaite plein succès dans
l'exécution de son mandat
j'exprime mes remerciements et ma
gratitude au secrétaire général des
nations unies monsieur antonio
littéraire qui conduit l'organisation
afin d'assumer son rôle protéger la paix
et la sécurité internationales et
réaliser la noble mission de cette
organisation ses effets se font
ressentir sur l'ensemble des peuples et
des pays notamment mon pays la
république du yémen
en effet les nations unies n'ont ménagé
aucun effort pour y établir la paix
durable et pourriez pour y relever les
défis notamment les défis humanitaires
je rends un vibrant hommage au grand
peuple yéménite au yémen et à l'étranger
à l'occasion des révolution glorieuse y
est mais ni de septembre et octobre qui
coïncide avec les réunions de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
mesdames et messieurs cela fait six ans
que les sessions de l'assemblée générale
se tiennent alors que nos maîtres
aversion des circonstances très
difficiles voire cruel à cause de la
guerre imposée à notre peuple par les
milices outils putschiste avec l'appui
régionale de l'iran ils ont fomenté
leurs plans après l'application de
l'initiative du golfe et son mécanisme
et après la tenue couronnée de succès de
la conférence du dialogue national
ces deux initiatives ont élaboré la
feuille de route pour l'avenir de mon
pays avec la participation de tout de
tous les mouvements politiques les
outils n'ont pas vu d'un bon oeil ces
développements ils ont d'une part d'été
chez laurette présentant à la table des
négociations mais de l'autre ils ont
préparé un
d'état ils ont mobilisé leurs sbires
pour faire chuter les villes et les
villages pour déplacer les citoyens de
leur village et de la région
ils ont même envahi la capitale sanaa en
septembre 2014
ils ont pris en otage les institutions
de l'état
hypothéquer la légimité et lui saper le
climat politique
asphyxié les libertés ils ont mené des
descentes dans les maisons ils ont fait
exploser les écoles et les lieux de
culte ils ont chassé les voix
discordantes
ils ont harcelé les citoyens et ils ont
transformé sanaa cette ville riche
d'histoire de civilisation et de
coexistence en une grande prison où la
population est enfermé monsieur le
président
les nations unies n'ont ménagé aucun
effort pour accompagner le processus de
transition politique au yémen depuis
2011 c'est à cette date qu'a commencé le
le processus de transition selon
l'initiative du golfe pour former un
gouvernement national pour convoquer des
élections présidentielles pour tenir une
conférence de dialogue national qui
réunit toutes les tranches de la société
yéménite pour élaborer une un projet de
nouvelle constitution pour le soumettre
à un référendum populaire et pour
l'adopter afin de tenir des élections
conformément à cette nouvelle
constitution est las le coup d'état
outil est arrivé en brisant ce processus
et se livrant à une guerre contre le
peuple yéménite monsieur le président
cette guerre guinée qui nous est imposée
à provoquer une catastrophe humanitaire
a déchiré la société yéménite et a
entraîné des vagues de déplacements
collectifs
elle a causé des vagues de répression et
de disparitions forcées ainsi que les
pires cas de pauvreté que l'on n'a
jamais connu nous tendons la main de la
paix nous avons tout fait pour soutenir
et faciliter les efforts des nations
unies et saison et sont envoyés au yémen
monsieur martin griffith et les envoyer
qui l'ont précédé l'objectif étant de
sauver le pays
et d'établir une paix juste et durable
l'objectif est temps d'arrêter
l'effusion de sang yéménite et la
catastrophe n'est minutes car le peuple
yéménite rejette le modèle iranien
quelles que soient les circonstances et
des fines
rappelons les concessions que nous avons
fait pour la paix pendant les cinq
dernières années rappelant notre
engagement aux côtés de nos soeurs et
frères dans la coalition pro les lignes
légitimité sous l'égide du royaume
d'arabie saoudite il ya quelques mois
pour instaurer un cessez le feu
unilatéral et permettre aux efforts de
monsieur martin griffith d'aboutir à un
cessez le feu durable et globale et
permettre une reprise de la du processus
politique
hélas ces efforts se sont heurtés à
l'obstination des milices outils
terroristes et leurs parrains dans le
régime iranien
pire encore ils ont saisi cette occasion
pour mobiliser pour attaquer les
gouvernorats et les villes pour
commettre davantage de carnage contre
les civils dans plusieurs gouvernorats
et ville au yémen vous assistez
aujourd'hui à une escalade sauvage menée
par ces milices notamment dans les
gouvernorats de marib algoud et al baïda
où ces milices ont lancé une lan à une
campagne militaire aveugle depuis
quelques mois ils attaquent les
quartiers résidentiels à l'aide de
missiles balistiques sans se soucier de
la vie des civils et des déplacés qui
ont fui les régions qui sont sous leur
contrôle et qui se comptent par milliers
ces milices terroristes prennent pour
cible de manière répétée les civils et
les institutions civiles au royaume
d'arabie saoudite
voici donc ce qui démontre les
véritables intentions des milices et
leur position de la vie vis-à-vis pardon
de la paix c'est pourquoi la communauté
internationale doit assumer son rôle et
mettre fin à cette arrogance et sa à
cette insolence pour mettre fin à la
souffrance de notre peuple
il faut faire pression de manier
active et déterminée sur les putschistes
et leurs parents pour qu'ils respectent
la résolution du conseil de sécurité au
sol et qu'il s'abstienne de se livrer à
l'effusion de sang et à la destruction
la d'humanitaire doit être disponible
pour tous des yéménites
je saisis cette occasion pour m'adresser
au monde afin de mettre la lumière sur
la souffrance de notre peuple qui
endurent toutes les formes de tragédie
de de torture et de conditions de vie à
cause de cette guerre des putschistes
nous remercions tous les frères tous les
amis toutes les organisations et pays
donateurs pour leurs efforts et leur
soutien
hélas ils n'ont pas échappé au chantage
et aux contraintes alors qu'ils essaient
d'atténuer la souffrance humaniste du
maine du peuple yéménite
alors que la guerre se poursuit et les
défis économiques que se multiplient ces
contraintes deviennent multiforme des
obstacles se multiplient face aux
gouvernements et aux institutions d'état
qui essayent de fournir les services qui
essaye d'assurer la reprise des services
et le retour à la normale dans la vie
dans les villes libérées
j'appelle à une mobilisation
internationale en appui aux efforts du
gouvernement pour lever les défis
économiques pour soutenir nos politiques
en faveur d'une devise nationale forte
pour assurer la stabilité des ménages la
communauté internationale doit rejeter
toutes les tentatives des outils de
manipuler l'aide humanitaire et faire
chanter le gouvernement et la communauté
internationale en pillant les fonds
réservés pour payer les salaires et en
insistant à miner les efforts des
nations unies
à cet égard j'appelle par ailleurs la
communauté internationale à s'engager de
manière sérieuse et urgente pour mettre
un terme à cette catastrophe imminente
du pétrolier s'affairent
d'ailleurs les milices outils refuse
l'accès de l'équipe onusienne aux
pétroliers pour mener des réparations et
mener des entretiens
monsieur le président
grâce à l'appui sans faille du royaume
d'arabie saoudite nous avons parcouru du
chemin pour appliquer l'accord du riad
qui assure la stabilité qui nous permet
de sortir de la crise dans la capitale
provisoire aden en août 2019
nous avons tout fait pour faciliter
l'application de cet accord car nous
sommes convaincus qu'il faut unir les
forts les efforts de tous pour réaliser
construction et de voeux et
développement sous l'égide du de l'état
depuis sa tribune
nous renouvelons notre notre confiance
au royaume d'arabie saoudite pour
poursuivre la mise en oeuvre de cet
accord
pour conclure je souhaite à cette
session plein succès je souhaite aux
nations unies davantage de développement
et d'efficacité au service de l'humanité
et de son bonheur
j'espère que ces résolutions seront à la
hauteur des grands défis qu'elle
rencontre au pays membres et à leurs
populations
je souhaite développement et prospérité
et à la communauté humaine je souhaite
bonheur bien être et prospérité et que
la pays la miséricorde de dieu soit avec
vous au nom de l'assemblée générale je
souhaite remercier le président de la
république du yémen de son allocution
je donne un présent la parole aux
représentants du burkina faso qui va
présenter une allocution de son chef
d'état madame la vice présidente
j'ai l'honneur d'introduire la
déclaration pré enregistrés de son
excellence monsieur roch marc christian
kaboré président du burkina faso à
l'occasion de la 75 ème session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
je vous remercie
[Musique]
monsieur le président monsieur le
secrétaire général de la cgt mesdames et
messieurs les chefs de délégations
distinguer délégué mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le président votre brillante
élection à la présidence de la soixante
quinzième session de l'assemblée
générale m'offre l'agréable occasion de
vous adresser mes vives félicitations
ainsi que celle de ma délégation
surprise en sortant cher professeur ian
et mohammad band et lorsque vous
accédiez à la présidence de la 74 ème
session de l'assemblée générale de la
société au titre de l'afrique
nous étions bien loin de nous imaginer
que notre organisation et de au delà
d'elle le monde entier connaître une
crise sanitaire aussi profonde que celle
lakovic 19 face à cette situation
imprévisible
vous avez su avec votre équipe vous
adapter aux nouvelles exigences et
relever les défis qui étaient les vôtres
pour assurer la continuité des activités
et le fonctionnement de l'assemblée
générale sur le secrétaire général le 22
janvier dernier vous avez présenté
devant l'assemblée générale
vos priorités 2020 en identifiant ce que
vous avez appelé les quatre cavaliers de
l'apocalypse que sont les tensions géo
stratégique mondiale la crise climatique
existentielle la méfiance croissante des
peuples partout dans le monde et le côté
obscur de monde numérique
malheureusement moins de deux mois après
un cinquième cavaliers de l'apocalypse
très destructeur la maladie a couronné
virus est apparu et s'est ajoutée aux
quatre déjà identifiés depuis lors vous
êtes pleinement investis pour que l'onu
se mobilisent pour faire face à la
pandémie et à ses conséquences
multidimensionnelle monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
chefs de délégation le 14 juin 2019
l'assemblée générale des nations-unies à
part la résolution 73 280
19 décidé de célébrer le 75e
anniversaire de notre organisation
commune sous le thème l'avenir ou le
volant l'onu qu'il nous faut réaffirmons
notre attachement collectif au
multilatéralisme
mais avec la crise mondiale déclenchée
par la pandémie de la couvrir 19 le
paysage l'assemblée générale a complété
le thème général de la célébration avec
la mention affronter la cohue et 19
grâce à une action multilatérale
efficace ce thème qui sous tend toutes
les activités réunions et conférences
organisées par l'onu en 2020 vient nous
rappeler les raisons fondamentales la
création de notre organisation pour la
commémoration de cet anniversaire nous
aurions tous aimé être présent
physiquement au siège à new york pour
célébrer ensemble les valeurs prônées
est défendu par les nations unies depuis
sa création en 1945
malheureusement la pandémie en a décidé
autrement
rappelant la fragilité du monde et notre
interdépendance dès le 9 mars 2020 le
burkina faso a enregistré ses premiers
pas de couvrir 19
le gouvernement a dû adapter ses actions
aux réalités du moment en prenant les
mesures de quarantaine et de confinement
des villes et des restrictions diverses
la pandémie de la poule 8 19 est une
crise multidimensionnelle qui risque
d'anéantir tous les efforts en matière
de développement dans de nombreux pays
surtout ceux touchés par les conflits
c'est pourquoi le burkina faso le mali
le secrétaire général de l'onu pour son
appel mondial à la solidarité
là c'est le 30 mars 2020 cet appel a
permis la mise en place d'un cadre
mondial visant à favoriser une réponse
intérêts et souple pour tirer le
meilleur parti de l'empreinte mondiale
du système onusien
je saisis l'occasion aux salué les
mesures d'allègement de la dette
20 des pays en développement mais
surtout pour lancer un appel pour son
annulation pure et simple
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les chefs de délégation il y a
de cela quelques mois la question de la
criminalité organisée et est
essentiellement l'alizé sous le prisme
de la lutte antiterroriste
aujourd'hui avec l'émergence de la
pandémie de la maladie à colonnades
virus et nous faute de rona va tenir
compte du triptyque criminalité
organisée terrorisme
coville 19 dans cette guerre contre le
terrorisme dans la région du sahel
je voudrais saluer le soutien et
l'accompagnement de labour et
internationale preuve s'il en était
encore besoin que la lutte contre le
terrorisme est une question de sécurité
internationale sur le volet purement
militaire un peu souliers des avancées
notables dans l'action de la force
conjointe du g5 sahel et des troupes
avaient aussi ne seront passés sous
silence l'implication fort appréciable
de ces vitesses général du conseil de
sécurité et de l'union européenne dans
la révision a fui vers 2020 de l'accord
technique en union européenne et les
nations unies et les g5 sahel qui permet
désormais d'étendre l'appui de la
minustah à la force majeure du g5 sahel
au delà des frontières du mali
cependant il faut regretter que la vie
de force n'est toujours pas atteint les
niveaux opérationnels souhaitait aussi
voudrais-je réitérer notre appel au
conseil de sécurité ou que cette force a
placé sous le chapitre 7 de la charte
des nations unies et bénéficier d'un
financement pérenne
je lance aussi un vibrant appel à tous
les partenaires à soutenir activement la
coalition internationale pour le sahel
créé en janvier 2020 à pau en force
monsieur le président distinguer
délégués dans notre lutte
contre le terrorisme des organisations
accuser nos forces de défense et de
sécurité d'exactions et de violations
des droits humains
je voudrais ici réaffirmer que nos
forces de défense et de sécurité
exécutent leurs missions dans le respect
des droits de l'homme notamment de droit
à la vie le droit à l'intégrité physique
des personnes tels que garantis par les
instruments juridiques auxquelles le
voka faso est parti toutes les fois où
les membres des forces de défense et de
sécurité ont été mises en cause par des
accusations
des enquêtes ont été ouvertes afin de
situer les responsabilités et de
sanctionner les auteurs je tiens à
rassurer les partenaires du burkina faso
et de la politique nationale qu'en dépit
de la modestie de nos moyens
les forces de défense et de sécurité
lutte contre le terrorisme avec
professionnalisme dans le strict respect
des règles d'engagement qui régissent
leur action en tout état de cause le
burkina faso ne ménagera aucun effort
pour relever les défis de la lutte
contre terrorisme pour garantir la
protection de ces populations et des
réfugiés et continuera est vrai pour
ramener la paix et la sécurité sur
l'ensemble du territoire national dans
le respect des règles du droit
international
dans ce sens le premier j'ai
dernièrement gouvernement marqué son
accord pour l'ouverture d'un bureau du
haut commissariat des nations unies aux
droits de l'homme au burkina faso
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les chefs des délégations au
burkina faso les électeurs aux urnes le
22 novembre 2020 pour les élections
couplées présidentielle et législatives
toute la classe politique majorité comme
opposition a décidé de manière
consensuelle d'aller aux élections en
dépit de l'insécurité qui prévaut dans
certaines régions du pays
je réaffirme l'engagement de mon
gouvernement à organiser des élections
transparentes
inclusive et apaisée à cet effet des
jets 2019 j'ai ainsi un cadre de
dialogue permanent avec l'ensemble des
composantes la classe politique
burkinabè pour lever les obstacles qui
viendra s'opposer tout au long du
processus
monsieur le président à distinguer
délégué au burkina faso nous avons pris
conscience très tôt de la nécessité de
préserver l'environnement dans toutes
nos politiques
les dispositions sont prises pour
inverser la tendance de la dégradation
de l'environnement et assurer
durablement la gestion des ressources
naturelles
les tragiques inondations de ces
dernières semaines dans notre pays et
dans plusieurs pays du continent
viennent rappeler la nécessité d'avoir
un engagement plus fort en faveur de l'
approche multilatérale incarné par la
convention cadre des nations unies sur
les changements climatiques
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les chefs des délégations le
burkina faso pays contributeurs de
troupes qui accompagnent les nationales
à la recherche de la paix a malgré sa
propre situation intérieure des prêts
1130 sommes dans un bataillon et des
unités de police constituées et 69
postes individuels
je saisis l'occasion pour réaffirmer la
disponibilité du burkina faso a toujours
s'engager aux côtés des nations unies
pour la recherche de la paix partout
dans le monde par le déploiement de son
personnel à des réformes et ses experts
judiciaires
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les chefs de délégation le
monde dans lequel nous vivons fait peur
car la paix et la sécurité
internationales sont menacés au vu des
tensions géo stratégique mondial
aujourd'hui encore les questions
africaines sont les plus nombreuses à
l'agenda du conseil de sécurité l'a pris
c'est que les terres qui persistent dans
la région du sahel et dans le bassin du
lac tchad est une véritable
préoccupation à laquelle il faut trouver
des réponses
sacha que la situation créée en libye en
est une des causes c'est donc dire que
règlement de la crise politique
un des gars de retour de la paix dans
ces régions aussi invitons le conseil de
sécurité a nommé le nouvel envoyé
spécial conjoint onu-union africaine
pour conduire les négociations au mali
nous appelons un règlement de la crise
politique et un retour rapide à l'ordre
constitutionnel et soutenant les
décisions de la cedeao pour une
transition civile sur le dossier du
sahara occidental
les avancées notables qui ont été
enregistrés suite à la tenue des deux
tables rondes dégénère entre l'algérie
le maroc la mauritanie et le polisario
mérite d'être consolidée et pour ce
faire
le burkina faso soit de la nomination du
nouvel envoyé spécial pour poursuivre
l'oeuvre de son prédécesseur sur la
situation au moyen orient et
singulièrement sur le conflit israélo
palestinien
il y avait les tamales lieu de relancer
les efforts diplomatiques visant à
mettre fin au conflit au sujet du blocus
économique commercial et financier
imposé à cuba depuis 1962
le bouquet la france aurait était son
appel pour sa levée
le burkina faso félicite cuba pour avoir
su endiguer la pandémie et par
solidarité internationale a envoyé des
centaines de médecins et personnels
soignants dans plus de 35 pays à travers
le monde en réponse à des demandes des
aides immédiates sur le président
distinguer délégué 75 ans après sa
création
après plus de vingt ans de négociations
inter-gouvernementales la réforme de la
chose unis se fait encore et toujours
attendre pourtant tout le monde
s'accorde à reconnaître qu'elle doit
permettre de réparer l'injustice faite à
l'afrique et que la revendication
africaine est une aspiration légitime
gérer et est donc le soutien de mon pays
à la position commune africaine tels que
reflétés dans le consensus
des illuminés et la déclaration de syrte
au terme desquels l'afrique doit être
pleinement représentés
et dans tous les organes de décision de
l'onu en particulier au conseil de
sécurité
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les chefs des délégations
mesdames et messieurs en adoptant le 21
septembre dernier la déclaration finale
de coopération du 75e anniversaire de
notre organisation nous avons reconnu
que notre organisation n'a pas atteint
le niveau que ses pères fondateurs
avaient souhaité car la pauvreté la faim
le terrorisme les services ou encore la
sécurité entre autres sont toujours
d'actualité face à ce constat nous
sommes engagés devant l'histoire à ne
laisser personne de côté
à promouvoir la paix et la coopération
digital est à prendre en compte les
jeunes les femmes et les filles dans
toutes nos politiques de développement
nous le connaissons l'interdépendance
des différents défis auxquels fait face
l onu lesquels ne peut être résolue que
par le renforcement du multilatéralisme
c'est pourquoi je fonde l'espoir que le
rapport de ce qu est un général qui nous
sera proposé avant la clôture de la
soixante quinzième session nous
permettra de regarder l'avenir avec plus
d'optimisme
une fois de plus nous réaffirmons notre
attachement collectif au
multilatéralisme
l'onu doit rester notre boussole commune
vers l'est la chance je n'ai vivre la
coopération internationale je vous
remercie
on forme des jeunes au nom de
l'assemblée générale je remercie le
président du burkina faso président du
conseil des ministres du burkina faso de
l'intervention qui vient de prononcer je
donne maintenant la parole aux
représentants de l'estonie afin qu'ils
présentent une déclaration du chef
d'état merci madame la présidente
même la présidente excellences mesdames
et messieurs j'ai l'honneur et le
plaisir de présenter la déclaration pré
enregistrés du président de la
république d'estonie son excellence
kersti et qu'elle lui wade à l'occasion
du débat général de la 64e session de
l'assemblée générale
mon président monsieur le président de
l'assemblée générale monsieur le
secrétaire général antonio guterres est
ce cher membres de la famille des
nations unies
chers frères chercheurs comme l'a écrit
l'auteur français albert camus il ait
eue dans le monde autant de peste que de
guerre et pourtant testé guerre trouve
toujours les gens toujours aussi
dépourvu l'an dernier nous étions tous
rassemblés à new york pour la
traditionnelle assemblée générale des
nations unies qui semble maintenant
appartenir à un passé distant et
l'occasion elle même semble appartenir à
un monde qui n'existe plus aujourd'hui
la pandémie qui a été un profond choc
pour notre mode de vie nous a également
apporté un enseignement un enseignement
sur la réelle portée du changement
climatique
la perte d'écosystèmes diversifiée des
risques liés à la cohabitation entre la
population et d'autres espèces dans des
villes surpeuplées
une amère préoccupation quant à la
survie de l'espèce humaine est un dur
labeur constant au sein des
organisations multilatérales afin de
nous assurer que nous puissions éviter
des conflits mondiaux
au sujet de
source limiter un enseignement sur la
nécessité de ne pas restreindre les
droits et libertés pour la survie des
plus aptes un enseignement quant à
l'importance des technologies et des
solutions numériques afin d'éviter les
risques sanitaires et d'éviter une
pollution superflu pour notre planète un
enseignement sur un partage équitable du
fardeau dans la lutte contre le
changement climatique au sujet d'un
accès équitable aux technologies afin de
promouvoir davantage l'égalité des
chances l'échelle mondiale un
enseignement sur des moyens justes et
transparents de nous assurer que les
technologies ne soit pas utilisé pour
nuire à nos sociétés l'estonie est le
premier pays du monde à avoir réalisé la
transformation numérique et tous nos
services publics sont disponibles en
ligne
la perturbation liée à la pandémie a été
limité grâce à l'application de
l'enseignement à distance et du
télétravail
nous avons vu une moindre rue et que
dans d'autres pays où il fallait
numériser des processus qui auparavant
se faisait exclusivement sur papier les
photos de président les fort taux de
pénétration de la technologie numérique
dans notre société
l'accès égal aux services numériques
promue par les secteurs public et privé
pour différents groupes d'âgés pour
différents groupes sociétaux associé à
une identité numérique que juridiquement
protégée ont été de la plus grande
utilité
nous souhaitons la même chose au reste
du monde nous voulons une égalité des
chances pour tous nous voulons que tout
un chacun ait la possibilité de
travailler à distance qu'il soit nous
souhaitons que tout un chacun et la
possibilité de voir leurs besoins
satisfaits en particulier pour les
personnes aux besoins spécifiques et
pour les femmes confinées dans leur
foyer afin qu'ils puissent travailler
grâce aux moyens numériques de manière
intermittente
lorsque leurs horaires leur permet nous
souhaitons voir un marché du travail
mondiale libre qui ne pousse pas les
gens à migrer mais qui les autorise
à vivre là où il le souhaite 30% des
emplois en estonie peuvent être
réalisées à distance
l'estonie qui a connu une
industrialisation tardive sert de modèle
pour les pays cherchant à réaliser un
bond de géant grâce aux technologies
nous contribuions au développement des
services électroniques à l'échelle
mondiale notamment en afrique par le
biais d'un mémorandum signé entre
l'estonie et l'union africaine
cette année nous organiserons également
un sommet mondial des entreprises
numérique avec l'aide des émirats arabes
unis
nos pme élabore des services numériques
pour les autres nations elle coopère
avec des partenaires locaux afin
d'élaborer des solutions sur mesure et
d'accroître la résilience des
écosystèmes numérique car nous le savons
chaque état numérique préservera son
identité et sa culture en ligne
également
c'est un avantage mais cela peut
également être un piège les dirigeants
mondiaux doivent comprendre que les
services numériques que ne permettent
pas à quelque pays que ce soit à elle
seule d'éliminer la bure a créé la
bureaucratie lourde la corruption ou
lésiné fake l'inefficacité en numérisant
ces problèmes nous risquons d'aggraver
la situation si simultanément nous ne
cherchons pas à accroître la
transparence et à rationaliser les
processus existants
par conséquent la numérisation peut
également entre nos étapes plus efficace
et rapprocher notre population
les technologies numériques servent
également à lutter contre les
changements climatiques
les réseaux intelligents de distribution
électrique que qui permettent de faire
converger l'offre et la demande en
électricité est d'élaborer des solutions
numériques pour ce faire fait partie de
l' économie sobre en carbone de l'avenir
la production en énergie verte quand
elle est intermittente
nous devons pouvoir équilibrer sa
production non seulement en renforçant
les capacités de réserve tels que les
systèmes de pompage turbinage ou encore
l'hydrogène mais nous devons également
réduire les pics de consommation en
adoptant des modes de consommation
intelligente d'une certaine manière la
pandémie séquence
quand nous offre une possibilité pour un
grand bond technologique mondiale les
solutions numériques que peuvent rendre
la société plus équitable résiliente
accessible et durable mais le
développement numérique présente
également des vulnérabilités et des
risques en matière de cyber sécurité en
tant que membres élus du conseil de
sécurité depuis janvier nous avons gardé
notre nous avons tenu notre promesse de
campagne de porter cette question à la
table du conseil de sécurité nous
l'avons fait en mars et on met encore
car la l'estonie tient toujours parole
chers collègues alors que nous luttons
contre une pandémie mondiale les menaces
conventionnelles et non conventionnelles
demeure une réalité le monde
d'aujourd'hui est tout aussi
imprévisible et dangereux qu'il l'était
y être prenons l'exemple des guerres en
ukraine ou en syrie ou encore du conflit
au sahel où la récente catastrophe
dévastatrice qui a frappé le liban ou
pensons aux graves violations des droits
humains au bélarus
dans l'ensemble la pandémie a même
exacerbée certaines conséquences des
conflits
par exemple lorsqu'il concerne la santé
et le bien-être des plus vulnérables les
enfants les femmes et les adolescents la
pandémie a également été utilisée en
tant que prétexte pour imposer des
sanctions ou restreindre l'aide
humanitaire deux nouvelles divisions ont
fait leur apparition
mes amis c'est inacceptable chères
familles des nations unies nous
célébrons notre 75ème anniversaire cette
année
l'onu est et demeure la pierre angulaire
de l'ordre multilatéral mondiale il n'y
a pas d'alternative à l'onu c'est
l'instance idoines afin de s'attaquer à
des questions mondiales passant de la
paix à la sécurité jusqu'à de nouvelles
menaces émergentes
c'est une instance où chacun a voix au
chapitre dc en estonie je peux vous
promettre que nous continuerons de
défendre le multilatéralisme et le droit
international
aussi imparfait puisse-t-il paraître
pour ceux à qui il tarde à qui il tarde
de résoudre la crise mondiale il n'y a
pas de meilleure option que l'onu
et nous demeurons un partenaire actif et
responsable pour tous les autres membres
de l'onu pendant cette crise et au delà
au nom de l'assemblée générale je
remercie la présidente de la république
d'estonie de sa déclaration
je donne à présent la parole au
représentant du malawi qui va présenter
une allocution de son chef d'état même
la présidente excellences mesdames et
messieurs j'ai l'honneur de présenter le
président de la république du malawi
président du groupe des pays moins
avancés pma son excellence le docteur
laser game à café shakira qui va
apporter sa contribution au débat
général de la 64e session de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies par
l'entremise d'une vidéo préenregistrée
je vous remercie
excellence monsieur volkan bosquet
président de la soixante quinzième
session de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies excellence monsieur
antonio godrèche secrétaire général des
nations unies
mesdames et messieurs chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs
je tiens tout d'abord à féliciter son
excellence monsieur volkan bosquet de
son élection à la présidence de la
soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
compter sur mon soutien et sur le
soutien du peuple et du gouvernement de
la république du malawi pendant votre
mandat et je m'adresse à présent
président sortant de l'assemblée
générale des nations unies son
excellence monsieur tidjani band et
merci de n'avoir pas ménager vos efforts
et d'avoir joué un rôle de chef de file
pendant votre mandat
hélas je me dois de vous exprimer à tous
et plus sincères condoléances au nom de
mon pays en mémoire de vos êtres chers
qui ont perdu la vie en raison de la
pandémie de covidien 10,9 et je souhaite
un prompt rétablissement à tous ceux qui
se remettent du virus
monsieur le président comme vous le
savez j'ai pris mes fonctions de
président de la république du malawi à
la suite de mon élection le 23 juin de
cette année mais c'est donc la première
fois que je fais une allocution devant
cette assemblée le processus qui a
débouché sur cette élection a certes été
long mais il a été pacifique et a
clairement confirmé l'arrêt petit cela
réputation du malawi modèle de
démocratie profonde et moins attachés au
respect des droits de la personne des
institutions de la gouvernance et de la
primauté du droit
la passation de pouvoir entre mon
prédécesseur et moi-même un permis de
créer un environnement pacifique et
confirmer notre vocation en tant que
choeur show de l'afrique
un pays que je me suis depuis engagé à
un gouvernant en me mettant au service
de la population selon une philosophie
qui s'appelle tu en sais c'est à dire
nous tous le seul président en
excellence je m'adresse à l'assemblée
générale en pleine lutte contre la
pandémie de covile 19 qui ravage les
systèmes de soins de santé dans le monde
entier et qui nuit gravement aux
économies de nos pays
le malawi membres des groupes des pays
moins avancés pma et du groupe des pays
en développement sans littoral le malawi
donc fait partie des pays les plus
durement touchés une situation encore
aggravée par un développement inégal les
difficultés que nous rencontrons sont
exacerbées par des obstacles
géographiques et autres tels que
l'absence d'accès à la mer l'isolément
l'éloignement des marchés mondiaux et
des coûts élevés de transit et de
transport tous ces obstacles entravent
notre compétitivité commerciale et notre
développement socioéconomique entravent
notre pleine participation au réseau de
production mondiale et aux chaînes
d'approvisionnement à ce sujet et en
tant que président du groupe des pma le
malawi a publié une déclaration le 25
avril 2020 mettant en exergue
elle est retombée de la pandémie de kovy
dit
9 en termes de risque élevé de défaut de
paiement de dégradation de la
compétitivité commerciale de
perturbations des chaînes
d'approvisionnement et de limitation du
secteur informel la déclaration lancé
également un appel à un soutien
international accru envers les pma eu
égard aux risques élevés et de défaut de
paiement
nous remercions le groupe de la banque
mondiale le fonds monétaire
international fmi l'organisation pour la
coopération économique et le
développement ocde et autres partenaires
clés du développement qui ont octroyé un
moratoire de la dette aux pma à la
lumière de la durée et de l'ampleur
potentielle de cette pandémie
nous demandons nous espérons à terme
obtenir une annulation de la dette
et dans l'intervalle une prorogation du
moratoire de la sorte les pma pourront
se relever de façon pérenne de cette
pandémie catastrophiques concernant le
commerce nous appelons de nos voeux des
mesures ciblées visant à remédier aux
perturbations des chaînes
d'approvisionnement
vous ne l'ignorez pas le malawi de
nombreux pma en deux grands secteurs
informels qui jouent des rôles clés pour
mobiliser les ressources nationales
grâce à l'envoi de fonds et la
production économique à petite échelle
voilà pourquoi nous saluons tous les
efforts visant à réduire les frais de
transaction imposé aux envois de fonds
et visant à mettre en oeuvre des
programmes de sauvetage et de
redressement des petites entreprises
je réitère notre volonté d'accueillir
la réunion d'examen régional pour
l'afrique des pma prévue pour en 2021
qui avait été reportée en tant que
président je saisis cette occasion pour
inviter tous les états membres pma le
secteur privé les organisations de la
société civile les institutions des
nations unies les amis des pma et toute
autre partie prenante à participer à la
5ème conférence des pma qui aura lieu en
janvier 2022 à doha au qatar ce sera là
l'occasion pour nous de préparer notre
plan d'action pour la décennie à venir
pour les pma et nous remercions l'état
du catr d'avoir accepté d'accueillir
cette manifestation crucial monsieur le
président excellence
le programme de développement durable
elle reste la plateforme du
développement international
coordonnées entre les états membres a
fortiori à l'heure actuelle alors que
nous nous heurtons à la menace la
pandémie de kobe de 19 et que la
coopération internationale et le
multilatéralisme ont été mises à mal
mais le malawi reste convaincu que nous
pouvons réaliser les eaux d'aidé dans
notre cas la réalisation des eaux d'aidé
est la meilleure façon de relever les
défis socio-économiques et de
concrétiser notre ambition d'une
création de richesses sans exclusive et
de davantage d'autonomie
par conséquent à l'aube de la décennie
d'action c'est à dire les dix dernières
années de la mise en oeuvre du programme
à l'horizon 2030
mon gouvernement continue de coopérer
avec le système des nations unies et
autres partenaires au développement dans
tous les domaines prioritaires pour
accélérer la mise en oeuvre des eaux
d'aider le malawi se concentre sur la
réalisation de cod dès qu'ils donneront
un nouvel élan à d'autres objectifs
de sorte à utiliser au mieux des maigres
ressources améliorer la participation de
toutes les parties prenantes et sauve a
fortiori en situation de pandémie
nous sommes fiers d'avoir mené le
premier examen national aux volontaires
lors du forum polityka de haut niveau de
cette année en juillet 2020 cet examen a
souligné les progrès remarquables que
nous avions consenti pour réaliser les
add et ce malgré l'avalanche de
difficultés mais nous demandons par
conséquent à nos partenaires de soutenir
davantage nos efforts de mise en oeuvre
c'est le président excellence nous
sommes conscients de l'importance
capitale de l'appropriation nationale
dans la
réalisation des eaux d'aidé le malawi a
repris les eaux d'aidé dans son cadre de
planification de développement national
à savoir la stratégie de croissance et
de développement du malawi mg ds3
conscient de la nécessité de disposer
d'institutions efficaces le malawi a
créé la commission de planification
nationale qui est chargé de transposer
les eaux d'aidé dans les plans de
développement nationaux
nous mettons également en oeuvre de
réformes du secteur public des réformes
promu au plus haut niveau au sein du
bureau de la vice présidence de la
république du malawi afin de rompre le
cercle vicieux de la sécurité
alimentaire de la malnutrition de la
vulnérabilité chronique au changement
climatique et aux catastrophes
mon gouvernement met en oeuvre la
stratégie de résilience nationale pour
la période allant de 2018 à 2030
une stratégie qui relie et les
interventions humanitaires et le
développement en donnant la priorité à
des mesures de soutien plus prévisible
ciblant les foyers les plus vulnérables
de sorte à ce que nos efforts de
développement ne fasse pas de laissés
pour compte
monsieur le président en excellence nous
prenons bonne note des efforts de
réforme des nations unies des efforts
défendu par le secrétaire général
nous rappelons que les nations unies
doivent être unis dans l action pour
garantir une mise en oeuvre aussi
efficace et efficiente du programme de
développement durable à l'horizon 2030
cela étant dit nous sommes préoccupés
par l'état d'avancement de réforme du
conseil de sécurité des nations unies
voilà pourquoi le malawi à lens à
nouveau
un appel pour que ces réformes se
poursuivent de toute urgence en
garantissant la pleine représentation de
l'afrique
conformément au consensus des uhnwi ni
de l'union africaine pour lever le
moindre doute nous demandons deux sièges
permanents avec droit de veto et cinq
sièges non permanents réservé à
l'afrique
les nations unies doivent pleinement
satisfaire les besoins de l'afrique dans
les processus de paix et cela ne pourra
se concrétiser que si l'afrique
participent à la prise de décision
compte tenu des conflits incessants qui
ravage à l'heure actuelle le continent
africain et qui entrave son progrès les
réformes sont plusieurs genres que
jamais monsieur le président excellence
les défis et les occasions dans le monde
de nous rappelle que nous sommes tous
reliés les uns aux autres la pandémie
nous convient de 19
les changements climatiques entre autres
défis sans dédé fidèlement titanesque
qu'il faudra l'unité du monde et des
solutions mondiales
ce 75e anniversaire des nations unies
est en soi une occasion de nous réjouir
est d'avoir remporté des victoires
collectives et de saluer la charte sur
laquelle repose notre unité il nous faut
oeuvrer de concert en tant que grande
famille mondiale
il nous faut faire tout notre possible
pour sauver des vies pour minimiser les
dégâts sociaux économiques plus que tout
il nous faut tirer les enseignements des
vulnérabilités des inégalités mondiales
qui ont été mis à jour par ce virus il
nous faut mobiliser des investissements
pérenne dans l'éducation la santé la
protection sociale et la résilience
mais le multilatéralisme va au delà de
la lutte contre les menaces communes le
multilatéralisme
c'est aussi saisir des occasions commune
il nous faut saisir cette occasion il
nous faut en sortir plus forts davantage
ouverts sur l'autre rien ne sert de
simplement prêcher les valeurs du
multilatéralisme encore faut-il le
joindre le geste à la parole
d'où la nécessité de faire participer
toutes les parties prenantes à notre
vision de l'avenir surtout les jeunes
qui sont majoritaires dans nos pays
monsieur le président excellence en ce
moment charnière pour la coopération
internationale et à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire des nations unies l'unité
est essentielle pour concrétiser notre
ambition commune d'un monde sans
équitable pacifique et durable
le malawi mises sont les partenariats
pour atteindre des objectifs communs
voilà pourquoi nous avons accepté la
responsabilité de présider le groupe des
pma jusque 2022
de même que la communauté du
développement d'afrique australe à
partir d'août 2021 notre siège au sein
du conseil paix et sécurité de l'union
africaine jusqu'à 2022 s'inscrit dans le
droit fil de cette conviction le malawi
s'est engagé à apporter sa modeste
contribution à tous les efforts des
nations unies y compris au sein du
conseil des droits de l'homme des
nations unies dont ne brigueront un
siège en 2021
comme le dit l'adage
charité bien ordonnée commence par soi
même
nous nous sommes engagés à continuer de
détacher un bataillon des forces de
défense du malawi auprès de la mission
de maintien de la paix des nations unies
au sein de la brigade d'intervention de
la sadec alès de la république du congo
démocratique du congo compter sur notre
modeste contribution pour faire en sorte
que les nations unies soit adapté à
l'objectif en ce 21ème siècle je vous
remercie de votre attention
que dieu nous bénisse on lui rapporte de
janos au nom de l'assemblée générale je
remercie le président de la république
du malawi de l'allocution qu'il a
prononcée
je donne maintenant la parole aux
représentants du congo afin qu'ils
présentent une allocution du chef d'état
madame présidente madame la présidente
excellence chers collègues j'ai
l'insigne honneur tout nous tous
madame la présidente chers collègues
c'est mon honneur de vous présenter la
vidéo préenregistrée de son excellence
dénis sassou nguesso président de la
république du congo à l'occasion du
débat général de cette 75e cession de
l'assemblage
mairal je vous remercie
sur le président de l'assemblée générale
et secrétaire général des nations unies
je voudrais monsieur le président vous
adresser mes vives félicitations pour
votre élection à la présidence de la
soixante quinzième session ordinaire de
l'assemblée générale de l'onu
je rend également un hommage mérité à
monsieur tijani - matt bande
votre prédécesseur pour le travail
réalisé lors de la 74e assemblée
générale je souhaite traduire toute ma
gratitude à messieurs antonio gutierrez
c'était général des nations unies pour
sa persévérance dans la recherche de
solutions aux différents défis auxquels
se trouve confrontée la communauté
internationale et c'est le président le
monde fait actuellement face à une crise
sanitaire inédite qui met en relief les
écarts flagrants entre les systèmes de
santé des pays développés et ceux des
pays en développement en termes de
capacité de riposte aux grandes
pandémies une situation interpelle les
acteurs bilatéraux et multilatéraux sur
les moyens adéquats
à mettre en oeuvre face à cette pandémie
qui affecte gravement la survie de
l'humanité
dès lors il importe d'intensifier la
solidarité internationale pour une
organisation harmonieuse et
complémentaire des stratégies afin
d'éradiquer cette pandémie
et c'est le président je note avec eux
un intérêt soutenu la haute portée du
thème de ce débat général à savoir
l'avenir que nous voulons l'onu qu'il
nous faut
réaffirmant notre attachement collectif
au multilatéralisme faire face à
l'accueil de 19 par une action
multilatérale efficace en effet
renforcer les mécanismes multilatéraux
de coopération dans le cadre de la lutte
contre le coronavirus télé et non c'est
le défi qui s'impose à l'ensemble de la
communauté internationale au regard de
l'ampleur des incidences économiques et
sanitaires induite par ce fléau
à n'en point douter
aucune sortie de cette crise sanitaire
sans précédent et aucun développement ne
sont désormais possibles en autarcie
l'onu reste donc le principal instrument
mesure de mobiliser les états dans le
cadre d'un effort de compromis voire de
consensus autour d'une action collective
contre les inégalités et les
vulnérabilités devant la conjoncture
difficile que traverse l'économie
mondiale
la réaffirmation du multilatéralisme
constitue le socle essentiel de l'action
internationale pour concrétiser nos
engagements collectifs en particulier
pour assurer l'accès à la couverture
stan était universel promouvoir
l'éducation pour tous
protéger l'environnement et préserver
durablement la paix sur le président en
célébrant le 75e anniversaire de l'onu
et malgré les progrès accomplis
nous assistons encore la résurgence des
privations insoutenable pour les peuples
ainsi restauration de la santé pour tous
en régie ceux des difficultés réelles
l'éradication de la pauvreté sur toutes
ses formes
reste une priorité internationale
cependant nous n'y parviendrons que si
les états disposent des ressources
nécessaires
dans un monde véritablement en paix sur
le président la république du congo est
préoccupé par la recrudescence du
terrorisme et de l'extrémisme violent
ainsi que par la prédominance des
conflits armés dans le monde il en est
ainsi de la crise libyenne dans les
ramifications affectent de plus en plus
les états du sed à ce sujet mon pays qui
assure la présidence du comité de haut
niveau de l'union africaine sur la libye
réaffirme la primauté d'une solution
politique favorisant la tenue de la
conférence interviennent inclusive de
réconciliation nationale les différentes
réunions tenues à brazzaville et la
conférence de berlin sur la paix en
libye ont encouragé les acteurs de ce
conflit à privilégier le dialogue dans
le cadre d'une approche multilatérale
un client l'onu à cet effet la feuille
de route adoptée le 30 janvier 2020 à
brazzaville reste d'actualité
l'est de la république démocratique du
congo reste toujours sous la menace de
groupes armés dans le même registre la
république centrafricaine qui se prépare
à une élection présidentielle
en décembre 2020 affichait une situation
rendu instable par l'activisme meutrier
des bandes armées
de son côté la syrie est toujours
confronté depuis 2011 à une guerre
civile aux conséquences dévastatrices
les relations israélo-palestiniennes
reste tendue en dépit des résolutions
pertinentes des nations unies prônons la
création de deux états indépendants
par ailleurs la situation de la
république de cuba appelle la levée des
sanctions unilatérales en conformité
avec la charte des nations unies
enfin le 75e anniversaire de l'onu
coïncide avec celui du refus mais
l'essai nucléaire
l'humanité se devrait de proske a jamais
lusage de l'armé nucléaire
monsieur le président au moment où nous
célébrons le 75e anniversaire de l'onu
ci vise toujours une injustice
historique qui lie c'est de réparer en
garantissant à l'afrique toute sa place
au sein du conseil de sécurité
en sa qualité de membre du comité des
dix de l'union africaine sur la réforme
du conseil de sécurité des nations unies
mon pays réaffirment solennellement
l'urgence de rendre effective la
représentativité de l'afrique au sein de
cet organe de l'onu
ainsi se consolideront davantage les
valeurs de paix de solidarité d'équité
et de ports et qu'incarne l'organisation
des nations unies vive le revenu vivre
la coopération internationale j'irai
vers ses innombrables et general au nom
de l'assemblée générale je souhaite
remercier le président de la république
du congo de la déclaration qu'il vient
de faire
je donne à présent la parole aux
représentants du bahreïn qui va
présenter une allocution de son chef
d'état
selon monsieur le président excellences
mesdames et messieurs j'ai l'insigne
honneur de présenter une intervention
préenregistrés de sa majesté le roi
hamad bin issa al khalifa roi du royaume
de bahreïn que dieu le protège
à l'occasion de la 64e session de
l'assemblée générale du lavoir manokwari
au nom de dieu le clément le mérite le
miséricordieux que la paix la
miséricorde et la bénédiction de dieu
soit avec vous monsieur le président
qu'il me soit permis d'emblée de vous
féliciter de votre élection en tant que
président de l'assemblée générale à sa
présente session
nous vous souhaitons plein succès lors
de l'exercice de votre monde
qu'il me soit également permis de
remercier le président de la précédente
session de l'assemblée générale des
efforts qu'il a consentis pour conduire
de manière si apte et efficace les
travaux de l'assemblée
c'est avec grand plaisir que nous nous
joignons à vous pour célébrer le 75e
anniversaire de l'organisation des
nations unies
ces dernières décennies l'onu a promu la
coopération internationale et a pu
préserver la paix mondiale en faveur de
l'ensemble de l'humanité
monsieur le président
qu'il me soit permis de saisir cette
occasion afin de saluer les efforts
infatigables consentis par son
excellence monsieur antonio guterres est
ce le secrétaire général de l'onu afin
de renforcer le rôle de l'organisation
rôle qui consiste à assurer le règlement
des différends et à proposer des
solutions et initiatives afin d'aboutir
à un ordre mondial fondé sur la
promotion et la protection des droits de
la personne et qui permettent d'assurer
le plus haut degré de développement égal
sur la base de la pleine participation
de tous les états membres
monsieur le président le royaume de
bahreïn soulignent qu'il est respectueux
de ses obligations internationales
obligations qui consistent à maintenir
un ordre international
robuste et stable nous continuerons de
jouer le rôle qui nous revient pour
assurer la paix dans le monde entier
nous souscrivons aux aspirations juste
de l'onu qui met en exergue la nécessité
d'agir de manière efficace ensemble afin
de surmonter tous les défis et toutes
les menaces
parmi lesquels en particulier les
énormes difficultés en matière de
développement et d'humanitaires et les
répercussions dont le monde a été témoin
en raison de la pandémie de lakovic 19
ce défi émergents l'a prouvé la
communauté internationale a
désespérément besoin de mettre de côté
ses différences et de promouvoir la
solidarité humaine
nous devons faire front commun face à
ces menaces sanitaires et nous devons
être mieux préparée afin d'éviter de
tels risques à l'avenir et avant
d'ériger des sociétés résiliente
monsieur le président nous saluons
l'appel lancé par le secrétaire général
en faveur d'un cessez le feu dans toutes
les zones de conflit de sorte à lutter
contre la pandémie
un appel qui a largement été accepté aux
quatre coins du monde
depuis le début de la pandémie le
royaume de bahreïn a fait preuve de
coopération de solidarité avec tous les
pays et institutions spécialisées y
compris l'organisation mondiale de la
santé et ses coordonnées avec ceux ci
face à cette situation difficile nous
avons créé un groupe de travail national
trouvant à sa tête
notre prince héritier de sorte à
élaborer et exécuter un plan d'urgence
intégré ce plan inclut nombre de mesures
nationales qui vont dans le droit fil
des meilleures pratiques existantes en
matière de prévention et de réparation
le plan national se concentre avant
toute chose sur la protection de la
santé et de la sécurité de nos citoyens
et résidents
nous avons tenu compte de la nécessité
impérieuse d'atténuer les conséquences
socio-économiques de la pandémie
nous travaillons d'arrache-pied à
diversifier nos programmes d'appui afin
d'assurer la prospérité et la stabilité
de la population et assurer la relance
rapide de l'économie nationale
monsieur le président nous accordons une
grande importance à la sécurité et à la
stabilité de la région
grâce à notre approche déterminée visant
à assurer l'ouverture et la coexistence
avec tout un chacun nous avons annoncé
l'établissement de relations avec l'état
d'israël envoyant ainsi un message
civilisé d'ouverture à une paix juste et
globale
cette paix est le meilleur garant pour
l'avenir de la population de la région
la mesure courageuse prise par l'état
fraternelle les émirats arabes unis
visant taha nouveau insuffler de
l'espoir quant à la possibilité de la
paix de la stabilité dans la région est
un succès louable en trouvant un accord
de paix historique avec israël sous les
auspices des états unis d'amérique
étant entendu qu israël mettrait un
terme à l'annexion des territoires
palestiniens les émirats arabes unis on
vous promet une chance de paix de
réduction des tensions et la chance
d'une nouvelle page pour la population
de la région
une page de concorde de rapprochement et
de coexistence pacifique
les émirats arabes unis ont également
conservé leur position ferme au sujet de
la cause palestinienne
nous nous félicitons d excellentes
efforts déployés par les états unis
d'amérique afin d'avancer dans cette
direction stratégique importante
monsieur le président
le royaume de bahreïn demande à ce que
les efforts seront intensifiés afin de
mettre un terme au conflit israélo
palestinien conformément à la solution à
deux états la solution à deux états est
la pierre angulaire d'une paix juste et
globale
elle devrait aboutir à la création d'un
état palestinien indépendant avec
jérusalem est comme capitale
sur la base des résolutions relatives à
la légitimité internationale et sur la
base de l'initiative de paix arabe
cela ouvrirait une nouvelle ère de
coopération et de relations de bon
voisinage permettant de consolider et de
promouvoir des intérêts communs dans la
région monsieur le président qui nous a
permis de saisir cette occasion afin
d'exprimer notre profonde reconnaissance
pour le rôle de pionnier et le dur
labeur réalisé par l'état frère du
royaume d'arabie saoudite eux menée par
notre frère le gardien des deux saintes
mosquées le roi salman bin abdulaziz al
saoud
l'arabie saoudite a non seulement jeté
les bases pour la sécurité et la paix
dans la région et le monde dans son
ensemble et ce faisant en tenant compte
des intérêts de toutes les parties
l'arabie saoudite a également consenti
des efforts remarquables et influente
dans le cadre de sa présidence du g20
afin de façonner une nouvelle décennie
qui réponde aux aspirations de tous les
peuples en faveur de la prospérité et de
la stabilité nous le soulignons le
royaume de bahreïn ne se tient côte à
côte avec le royaume d'arabie saoudite
notre grand frère en tout temps dans le
cadre de ses positions nous exprimons
également notre pièce notre plein
soutien en faveur des efforts continus
déployés par l'état frère de la
république arabe d'égypte
afin de consolider la sécurité la
stabilité régionale nous appuyons
fermement les véritables les efforts
consentis afin d'assurer la paix y
compris d'initiative récemment lancé par
notre frère le président abdel fattah
al-sisi qui a donné de l'espoir aux
peuples le fraternel libyen afin de
résister à l'interférence étrangère
cette initiative a contribué au
renforcement des capacités des pays de
la région sur la base du rôle de
pionnier joué par l'egypte pour protéger
et maintenir la sécurité nationale arabe
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les représentants le succès et
la prospérité des sociétés sont fondées
sur leur sécurité et leur stabilité
c'est la devise même du royaume de
bahreïn en tant que membre actif de la
communauté internationale le royaume de
bahreïn soulignent qu'il est nécessaire
d'accélérer les efforts afin d'assurer
la prospérité humaine
pour ce faire il convient de promouvoir
la solidarité et le consensus dans le
cadre d'objectifs mondiaux
nous nous sommes nous même engagé en
faveur de ses objectifs depuis la
fondation de cette noble organisation
aujourd'hui nous célébrons
l'anniversaire de notre organisation et
nous louie souhaitons que ce moment
charnière de l'histoire contemporaine
marque pour l'organisation à nouveau
départ monsieur le président nous sommes
fiers du rôle que nous jouons et nous
sommes engagés à apporter un appui aux
nations unies afin d'aboutir à nos
objectifs
afin de répondre aux aspirations
légitimes de la population et restaurer
la confiance et l'amour de sorte à
assurer un monde plus pacifique et sûr
merci monsieur le président
et que la paix la miséricorde et la
bénédiction de dieu soit avec vous ils
nombre l assemblée générale
bahreïn pour cette allocution
je donne maintenant la parole à la
délégation du botswana pour la
présentation de l'allocution du chef
d'état monsieur le vice-président
excellence chers collègues
c'est pour moi un grand plaisir
d'introduire la locution préenregistrés
de son excellence docteur mukwege est si
eric k masisi président de la république
du botswana je vous remercie monsieur le
président excellences mesdames et
messieurs je suis très honoré de
m'adresser à la soixante quinzième
session de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies pour la première fois
depuis le renouvellement de mon mandat
en tant que président après les
élections générales du 23 octobre 2019
cet ensemble est unique à bien des
égards elle marque le 75e anniversaire
des nations unies elle se tient de façon
virtuelle
elle se tient dans le contexte du jeu
plus grands défis de notre époque
la pandémie de covile 19 permettez-moi
par conséquent de transmettre mes
sincères condoléances aux familles et
aux amis qui un peu partout dans le
monde ont été frappés par cette pandémie
je rend également un hommage particulier
à tous ceux qui se battent contre ce
virus en première ligne je suis certain
que comme nous l'avons fait par le passé
nous serons ensemble nous battre contre
ce défi et en sortir plus sage plus fort
et plus résilients et davantage préparés
pour faire face à des pandémies
semblables monsieur le président comme
les délégations qui se sont exprimées
avant moi je vous félicite pour votre
accession à la presse
ans de la soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
le nous félicitons de priorité que vous
avez présenté et vous pouvez compter sur
le plein soutien de ma délégation dans
l'exécution de votre mandat je saisis
également cette occasion de dire toute
notre reconnaissance à votre
prédécesseur son excellence le
professeur tidjani mohammad band et qui
a su guider l'assemblée générale pendant
sa soixante quatorzième session
monsieur le président le botswana se
rallie à la thématique de cette 75e
session l'avenir que nous voulons l'onu
qu'il nous faut réaffirmons notre
attachement collectif au
multilatéralisme faire face à la coved
19 au moyen d'une réelle action
multilatérale
cette thématique nous rappelle de façon
opportune la valeur et la signification
du multilatéralisme en tant que cadre
ultime pour trouver des solutions
durables aux défis existants et
émergeants dans le monde
le monde est beaucoup plus sûre lorsque
nos pays travaillent de concert à des
réponses collectives aux menaces
complexes de notre époque
aujourd'hui plus que jamais l'action
multilatérale est nécessaire pour faire
face de façon efficace à une crise de
santé publique mondiale et urgente d'une
nature inédite depuis la grippe
espagnole de 1918 nous en convenons tous
notre coopération à tous sera nécessaire
pour redresser les économies dévastée de
nos pays et pour rétablir les moyens
d'existence de nos sociétés en tant que
principale institution multilatérale et
nations unies et son agent spécialisé la
plus remarquable
l'organisation mondiale de la santé sont
les mieux placés pour mobiliser les
efforts nécessaires sur le long terme et
le court terme face à la pandémie
nous savons notre organisation a été
rapide pour soutenir les efforts
nationaux dans les régions les plus
fragiles du monde notamment à travers
les vols de la solidarité des nations
unies qui ont livré des équipements
médicaux vitaux aux personnes qui en
avaient le plus besoin
ma délégation se félicite de ces
initiatives
et des mesures de réaction urgente
prises par le système des nations unies
notamment à travers les équipes et des
nations unies de nous félicitons plus
particulièrement du rôle de chef de file
joué par le secrétaire général pendant
cette époque sans exemple et nous nous
félicitons en particulier de son appel à
un cessez le feu mondial ainsi qu'à la
l'élaboration d'un vaccin abordable pour
la copie 19 qui doit être accessible par
tous et partout
monsieur le président alors que nous
réfléchissons la façon dont nous pouvons
nous appuyer sur le multilatéralisme la
coopération internationale pour mieux
relever les défis de la copie 19 il nous
appartient également de nous pencher sur
la façon dont nous pouvons renforcer les
capacités de réaction des nations unies
cela doit être également l'occasion de
redoubler d'ambition dans la réalisation
du programme 2030 l'avenir que nous
voulons nous devons consolider l'élan
d'accélération des eaux d'aidé en nous
appuyant sur l'appel du secrétaire
général à une décennie d'action le
programme 2030 de développement durable
monsieur le président le programme 2030
de développement durable et ses
objectifs de développement durable au
d'aidé constitue une feuille de route
solide qui doit continuer de nous guider
dans nos plans mondiaux et nationaux au
botswana nous restons déterminés à
accélérer nos efforts pour réaliser les
eaux d'aidé pendant cette décennie
d'action qu'il nous reste pour
concrétiser cette ambition gouvernement
est déterminé à transformer l'économie
une économie qui actuellement repose
principalement sur les industries
extractives qui sont vulnérables aux
chocs internationaux pour devenir une
économie de la connaissance mon
gouvernement à cette fin a introduit des
réformes économiques pour stimuler une
transformation rapide dans de nombreux
secteurs
nos mesures visent à créer un
environnement favorable au secteur privé
conformément à l'objectif 8 travail
décent et croissance économique
monsieur le président comme je
l'évoquais au botswana comme dans
beaucoup de pays la pandémie il ya eu
des répercussions très profonde sur nos
vies et sur nos moyens d
distance notre secteur de la santé était
déjà vulnérables et la pandémie est un
défi de plus qui s'ajoute à la mortalité
infantile les maladies non
transmissibles le vih et le sida
pour répondre à la prévalence croissante
des maladies non transmissibles mon
gouvernement a adopté une stratégie
multisectorielle de prévention et de
contrôle des maladies non transmissibles
pour 2018 2023 cette stratégie se
concentre sur les mesures de prévention
et sur l'amélioration de la qualité de
vie des personnes concernées
nous menons depuis longtemps une
bataille contre le vih et le sida cela
reste une priorité essentielle de mon
gouvernement je suis heureux à cet égard
de vous indiquer que le botswana est
bien engagée sur la voie de la
réalisation du programme conjoint des
nations unies sur le vih/sida 90 90 90
le l'objectif de traitement de l'onu
sida
86% des personnes vivant avec le sida
ont été testés connaissent leur statut
et sur les personnes qui connaissent ce
statut 83 sont traités et chez 90% le
virus est contenue monsieur le président
le botswana accélère son accès à une
éducation équitable inclusive et de
qualité notamment à travers
l'application du plan stratégique pour
le secteur de l'éducation et de la
formation
ce plan ambitionne de transformer
l'apprentissage en assurant l'accès à
l'éducation la rétention dans le système
scolaire et en promouvant
l'apprentissage tout au long de la vie
et le développement des compétences
éradication de la pauvreté monsieur le
président avant la pandémie
il était estimé que son 4 783 millions
de personnes vivaient dans la pauvreté
extrême dans le monde
en juin 2020 la banque mondiale 1
prévoyait que la pandémie risquer de
faire basculer 71 millions de personnes
supplémentaires dans la pauvreté extrême
en 2020 anéantissant ainsi et les
progrès réalisés ces dernières décennies
une telle réalité exige donc une action
collective urgente si nous voulons
éradiquer la pauvreté dans toutes ses
formes multi dimensionnelle partout et
pour tous d'ici 2030 pour sa part mon
gouvernement continuera d'autonomiser
est d'aider les pauvres à travers
différents programmes d'éradication de
la pauvreté ces programmes permettent
aux bénéficiaires de créer des micro ou
petites entreprises pour vivre dans de
meilleures conditions
des programmes ont permis de tirer les
bénéficiaires de la pauvreté à travers
une création de sources de revenus de
moyens d'existence stable monsieur le
président ma délégation note
l'augmentation déplorables au niveau
mondial des violences contre les femmes
et les filles dans le contexte de la
crise sanitaire
alors que les pays se confinait et que
chacun reste chez soi beaucoup de femmes
et de filles malheureusement sont
devenus une proie facile pour les
prédateurs humains et ont été victimes
de violences sexistes cette tendance
foule au pied les aspirations de
l'objectif 5 égalité entre les sexes et
nécessite donc de notre part des efforts
collectifs et acharné le fléau des
violences sexistes était déjà une
préoccupation au botswana et la
prévalence a augmenté de façon alarmante
depuis le début de la crise de kobe 19
pour lutter contre ce problème aux
gouvernements à intensifier
l'application de la stratégie nationale
pour éradiquer la violence sexiste
la réaction du botswana face à la copie
de 19 monsieur le président comme je
l'indiquais lakovic 19 a été très
néfaste à l'économie du bois tswana la
suspension des voyages internationaux et
l'effondrement économique mondiale ont
été un coup très dur porté aux deux
principaux piliers de notre économie le
tourisme et l'exploitation diamantifère
les confinements répétées et des autres
protocoles de covile 19 ont également
beaucoup réduit notre activité
économique dans sa réaction le
gouvernement a mis en place un plan de
soutien à l'économie afin d'aider
l'économie et compléter les mesures de
contention de la maladie le gouvernement
travaille actuellement à un plan de
relèvement économique et de
transformation qui vise à soutenir la le
rétablissement de l'activité économique
faciliter la croissance économique
accéléré la transformation économique et
bâtir une côte
résiliente notre économie a connu de
fortes perturbations et notre
gouvernement néanmoins reste déterminé à
atteindre les objectifs fixés dans ses
politiques et programmes de
développement durable de la banque au
vide le plan économique de
rétablissement et de transformation
permettra de donner un nouvel élan à
toutes ces initiatives
monsieur le président comme pour tout
problème mondial les états nations n'ont
pas les moyens de lutter contre la
pandémie de covidien a fait ses effets à
eux seuls une réaction multilatérale est
impératif cela ne fait aucun doute
c'est pourquoi nous nous faisons l'écho
de l'appel à un multilatéralisme fondée
sur les règles un multilatéralisme
inclusif ouvert aux voix de la société
civile du secteur privé et du monde
universitaire qui sont autant de
partenaires et de parties prenantes
indispensable pour façonner nos
politiques mondiales pour le botswana
une réponse multilatérale idéal serait
une réponse qui soit axée à la fois sur
le court et sur le long terme dans le
court terme il est nécessaire de
proposer aux pays et peuples vulnérables
des mesures de dead et de sécurité
immédiates sur le long terme des efforts
multilatéraux de relèvement pour la
préco vite sont nécessaires pour
soutenir comme il se doit les pays et
les populations les plus fragiles
ma délégation accueillie donc
favorablement l'idée d'un relèvement se
concentrant sur une reconstruction
plus rapide plus vertes est meilleur et
mettre l'accent sur la résilience cet
essentiel plus essentielle que jamais
pour les pays sortant d'un conflit ou
d'autres crises humanitaires ainsi que
les pays qui vivent malheureusement sous
occupation étrangère
le botswana s'intéresse également de
près à l'appui donné au pays en
situations particulières comme les pays
les moins avancés les pays en
développement sans littoral et les
petits états en suler en développement
qui sont les pays les plus vulnérables
des nations unies nous sommes nous mêmes
un pays enclavé et pendant cette
pandémie nous avons rencontré des
difficultés à faire circuler les biens
et services à cause de la fermeture des
frontières dans ce contexte nous
appelons à ce cas un effort
supplémentaire soit fait pour accélérer
la mise en oeuvre du programme d'action
de vie
du programme d'action d'istanbul et des
modalités d'action de samoa conçu pour
améliorer les conditions de ces pays
pour que le cadre multilatéral des
nations unies soit efficace dans la
lutte contre la pandémie de kobe 19 et
d'autres défis les nations unies doivent
être souple dynamique et adaptés à leurs
objectifs
depuis le début de la crise nous avons
constaté que le secrétariat disposait de
ses qualités organisationnelles
nous en avons eu la preuve dans sa
réponse même si le résultat des réformes
n'a pas encore été évaluée ma délégation
constate que les réformes de la gestion
ont permis d'améliorer certains aspects
de la réaction opérationnel face aux
crises nous pensons qu'il ya encore des
efforts à faire néanmoins nous
encourageons l'assemblée générale et les
autres organes principaux à renforcer
leurs efforts de réforme
monsieur le président le changement
climatique le coc vide 19 est une
pandémie dévastatrice qui a pris au
dépourvu le monde mais le changement
climatique lui est un phénomène que nous
connaissons bien et nous pouvons nous
prévaloir contre ses répercussions
cela fait longtemps que le climat
changement climatique est considérée
comme une menace existentielle et nous
restons déterminés à contenir la
dévastation qu'ils s'aiment
nous devons donc redoubler d'efforts
pour en atténuer les effets négatifs
le botswana est un pays semi aride à
pluviométrie irrégulière nous
connaissons des sécheresses fréquentes
et c'est pourquoi nous attachons une
grande importance à l'objectif très
action climatique notre climat a une
incidence sur les moyens d'existence
puisque cela perturbe la production
alimentaire en outre des sécheresses
récentes ont tari des sources d'eau y
compris pour la faune et la flore
sauvages cela a contribué à d un mort
d'animaux et à la vivement des tensions
entre humains et faune sauvage pour
renforcer l'adaptation l'atténuation mon
gouvernement met au point une politique
de réaction face aux changements
climatiques et un plan national
d'adaptation ne travaillant que la
société civile le monde universitaire et
les partenaires internationaux pour
accélérer la
en oeuvre de nos engagements au titre de
l'accord de paris les droits de l'homme
monsieur le président le botswana
souscrit pleinement aux trois piliers se
renforçant mutuellement sur lesquels les
nations unies repose depuis leur
fondation nous d'argon que la promotion
et la protection des droits de la
personne la démocratie et l'état de
droit sont essentiels pour assurer le
développement durable la paix et la
sécurité
monsieur le président je saisis
également cette occasion de réaffirmer
le soutien du botswana à l'endroit du
conseil des droits de l'homme pour le
travail ambitieux qu'il accomplit et qui
permet de faire progresser le dossier
des droits de la personne partout dans
le monde paie sécurité internationale
monsieur le président ma délégation
applaudit les efforts constants que
confronté nations unies pour maintenir
la paix la sécurité mondiale même dans
le contexte de la pandémie
nous nous félicitons de l'appel de
secrétaire général en faveur d'un
cessez-le-feu mondiale et des efforts de
suspension des conflits armés pour
permettre au monde de se concentrer sur
la bataille que nous devons livrer de
toute urgence contre la pandémie
nous nous félicitons également du plan
de réaction humanitaire mondial contre
la copie 19 qui a été conçu pour aider
les groupes les plus vulnérables en
particulier dans les pays en conflit et
les pays à faible revenu davantage de
partenariats et de financement par les
donateurs sont néanmoins nécessaires
pour que ce plan portant puissent être
pleinement appliquée monsieur le
président je passe maintenant à la paix
et à la stabilité en afrique australe
ma région même si notre région reste
relativement stable nous voyons la paix
et la sécurité de plus en plus menacée à
cause d'actes de terrorisme et
d'insurrection en tant que président
actuel de l'organe de politique défense
et coopération pour la sécurité de la
sadec le botswana est déterminée à
suivre de près cet impératif de lutte
contre le perron de terrorisme et autres
menaces de sécurité afin d'améliorer la
paix et la stabilité dans la région de
la sadec monsieur le président il a été
établi de façon certaine que le
terrorisme ne connaît pas de frontières
il reste une menace grave pour la paix
la sécurité internationales le botswana
reste déterminé à lutter contre le
terrorisme sous toutes ses formes nous
continue donc de prendre les mesures
nécessaires
pour prévenir et lutter contre ce fléau
cela passe notamment par le renforcement
de notre régime de lutte contre le
blanchiment d'argent et le financement
du terrorisme
c'est là la preuve de notre engagement
très ferme à contribuer à la sécurité
l'intégrité du système financier mondial
nous nous félicitons du soutien du
bureau des nations unies contre le
terrorisme et d'autres partenaires pour
renforcer des capacités du de lagence
nouvellement créée par le botswana
chargé de l'analyse antiterroriste afin
de nous permettre d'atténuer notre
exposé notre vulnérabilité face à cette
menace
pour conclure je réaffirme notre
fidélité au multilatéralisme et à la
coopération internationale qui sont des
mécanismes indispensables pour la paix
la sécurité la promotion des droits de
la personne et le développement durable
il ne fait aucun doute que les nations
unies sont tout aussi pertinente qu'elle
était il ya 75 ans est ce à cause des
défis complexes et multi facettes
auxquels l'humanité est confrontée
aujourd'hui les enseignements de la
pandémie de covile 19 et d'autres crises
seront certainement déterminante pour
façonner l'avenir que nous voulons et
les nations unies qu'il nous faut pour
bâtir rapidement un monde plus juste
pacifique et prospère pour les
générations futures je vous remercie de
votre attention le nombre et l'assemblée
générale au nom de l'assemblée générale
je remercie le président de la
république du botswana pour cette
déclaration
et je donne maintenant la parole aux
représentants de la guinée afin qu'ils
nous présentent allocution du chef
d'état monsieur le président distingué
délégué dames et messieurs j'ai
l'honneur et le privilège d'introduire
l'allocution de son excellence
professeur alpha condé président de la
république de guinée à l'occasion du
débat général de la 66ème session
ordinaire de l'assemblée générale des
nations unies je vous remercie
mais c'est le président excellences
mesdames messieurs les chefs d'état et
de gouvernement mais c'est déjà des
nations unies madame messieurs les
délégués c'est pour moi un grand honneur
de m'adresser à cette auguste assemblée
ne conteste pas le cuir chargé de vives
émotions des défis et d'interrogations
quant à la venue du monde confrontés
depuis des mois la grave pandémie 2009
je tiens à adresser les sincères quand
l'élan du peuple et 12 madeleine à
toutes les familles endeuillées
affable le monde passe elle crée du
courant à gries ya une urgence sanitaire
sans précédent lundi soir et 102 le menu
pied je souhaite un prompt
rétablissement aux malades atteints par
ces milices mais c'est le paiement je
vais là vous avez c'est mes chaleureuses
féliciations suite à votre brillante
élection à la présidence de la 75 ème
session du assemblée générale
vous assurez mon soutien de la peine que
personne la délégation
je tiens également à la naine hommage
mérité au pcf
si j'en ai moi-même gbagbo président
sortant qui assumait ces fonctions avec
efficacité dans le confinement
il fallait fait plus d'imagination afin
d'expérimenter de nouvelles méthodes de
savin le prendre aux nombreuses
sollicitations liées à la gestion des
buts importants d'assemblées générales
dans l'ain la cdu rodez souto exclu mais
à mes yeux les effets gênants santini nc
antonio gutiérrez la gratitude la fugue
les fossés sédatives 2 et salutaire en
faveur de la préservation de la paix de
la sécurité nationale et la fia sont
attelés 500 h1 n1 mais c'est le prénom
d'un 02 confronté hélas à divers défis
le thème de la présente session
la vrai que nous voulons le nie qu'il
nous faut réaffirmons notre attachement
multilatéralisme nous interpelle à
jamais l'autre central de l'onu et son
leadership s'imposent à tous les états
membres aux pour moi et renforcer le
multilatéralisme n'assumant de plus en
plus interdépendant aucun état ne peut à
lui seul affronter les défis nombreux
divers auxquels l'humanité est
confrontée à travers ses multiples
champs d'action et sac à passer de
connaissances d'intervention
internationale
l'une est à comparer les états membres
dans l'atteinte des objectifs de
développement de l'éducation là pour
l'été et la vue ou le lac les incendies
chances mathématiques le monde a plus
que jamais besoin du langage ont réformé
faute à 10h et la bad valeur constaté
leurs achats tu es la déclaration
universelle dans le rend capable à
travers ses institutions spécialisées dû
faire face aux défis de la paix il
reprend durable et la santé
ces 115 après sa création nous sommes en
mesure d'affirmer et les nations unies
ont su répondre à l'attenté profonde à
terre là leur faut le préserver les
générations futures du fléau d'une
troisième guerre mondiale ne pouvoir la
paix est développée entre les nations
relations d'amitié de coopération une
gouvernance et l assureur et river
renforcée va prendre davantage en
considération les intérêts des pays en
2003 notamment de la mise en réseau
d'aidé et les programmes d'action de la
troisième fois fandel du sabre à ses
finances en vidéo le roi édouard
engagement à thuir s'élancer passionnel
un mondial copie
folan se lever et poussières de l'agenda
développement de graves lacunes et
s'annule lancement de la décennie
d'action pour les aider dès qu'ils
commandent aux valves ambitions à la
hausse et a scellé la mise en oeuvre de
solutions idoines rural au défi la
pauvreté l'inégalité des sexes de
conflits des changements climatiques et
ligue à financer dans la mise en oeuvre
des jeux dédiés dans ce cadre d'arrivée
guinée à intégrer toutes les questions
importantes relatives à la mise en eau
des bébés dans son plan national de
développement pour créer la croissance
et la postérité
enfin vers le couple à chacune un effet
la guinée un pays émergent grâce au
partenariat bi et multilatérales et
s'attellent à la mise en oeuvre des
objectifs du bloc populaire
dans le cas de son plat nations en
développement économique et social prds
2016 2020
notre pays s'est doté d'instruments
efficaces comme l' agence d'argent des
financements des cultures locales en
afrique
l'agencé nationale d'inclusion
économique et social année est et le
fond lui apprendre local folle elle en
europe
dans le cas de la gestion de cette crise
un tel talent vue du guinée à l'instar
des autres pays du monde
durement éprouvé par le qu'on a vu à
l'obtient plan du procès ruby ce décret
et abusant sanitaires légers objet de ce
plan national vise à contrôler et gérer
la pandémie a tiré les conséquences de
la crise notamment sur les ménages en
situation de précarité et annuler les
effets de la pandémie c'est les petites
et moyennes entreprises
en quoi ces scientifiques est fausse a
été créé pour orienter et renforcé les
mesures de lutte contre la pandémie avec
l'objectif d'éradiquer et stopper la
progression du conte harissa peuvent le
pays
le coût financier du plan est de face à
saint-gall 1000 $ us les populations
guinéennes y adhèrent et sont impliqués
dans sa mise en oeuvre à se basant sur
les chemins de la gestion des épidémies
avis ebola
je voudrais saisir cette occasion pour
renouveler la reconnaissance de la
guinée à ses partenaires techniques et
financiers et aux pays amis pour leur
soutien coinçant décisif et
complémentaire aux fai nationaux de
l'éducation du serpent de nier ma
délégation exprime le souhait de
watchguard à la dga sont politiques sous
la couverture sanitaire mondiale
l'inclusion du principe de l'accès
universel à la santé publique nous le
voir rien ménagé pour considère mandat
persécutés à léguer aux générations
futures
je voulais merci
nombreux lots non de l'assemblée
générale je remercie le président de la
république de guinée pour l'allocution
qui vient de prononcer je donne la
parole à la délégation de la gambie afin
qu'ils nous présentent l'allocution du
chef d'état d'un doublement de musique
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
excellences mesdames et messieurs les
délégués j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter la locution préenregistrés de
son excellence monsieur adama barro
président de la république de gambie
à l'occasion de la soixante quinzième
session du débat général des nations
unies merci monsieur le président
monsieur le secrétaire général majesté
mesdames et messieurs les chefs d'état
et de gouvernement mesdames et messieurs
au nom de ma délégation
je vous salue chaleureusement
depuis la gambie à l'occasion du 75e
anniversaire de la création des nations
unies
malheureusement cet anniversaire
coïncide avec la pandémie international
de covile 19
c'est pourquoi nous faisons part de nos
plus sincères condoléances à tous ceux
qui ont perdu des proches en raison de
cette pandémie monsieur le président
[Musique]
nous allons le thème choisi pour la
soixante quinzième session du débat
général de l'assemblée générale l'avenir
que nous voulons les nations unies dont
nous avons besoin réaffirmer notre
engagement collectif en faveur du
multilatéralisme lutter contre la
conduite 19 grâce à des mesures
multilatérales efficace
en tant qu'humanité notre avenir est
interdépendant et la pandémie à kovy 19
la faire ressortir clairement cette
pandémie a mis en lumière la sagesse et
l'importance d'élaborer des stratégies
collectives des approches des solutions
communes pour relever les défis
internationaux monsieur le président il
convient urgemment de défendre nos
institutions multilatérales en prenant
des mesures légitimes au sujet des
questions traitées par les nations unies
cela débouchera sur l'établissement le
maintien de la paix et la coopération
dans un l'ordre dans le cadre d'un ordre
mondial stable monsieur le président
pour atteindre cet objectif nous devons
créer les moyens d'entendre et de
répondre aux préoccupations et intérêts
de tous les états membres pour les
petits états tels que celui de la gambie
l'onu a toujours été une enceinte de
négociations de discussion de
coopération et de collaboration pour le
bien d'action internationale collective
c'est pourquoi nous réaffirmons notre
engagement en faveur de la charte et des
buts et principes des nations unies
monsieur le président
la charte à doter nos institutions de
capacité à régler toutes sortes de crise
tels que la flambée de cette pandémie
qui menace notre existence
très honnêtement notre riposte à la
pandémie doit être la hauteur de
l'ampleur de la difficulté les
dévastations sont immenses dans d'un
point de vue de pertes de vies humaines
de pertes économiques de répercussions
sociales et émotionnelles sur nos
nations nos communautés et les 10 et les
individus une solution multilatérale est
la moyenne meilleur moyen de garantir la
sécurité et la relance pour chacun
d'entre nous monsieur le président les
systèmes de soins de santé à travers le
monde sont en difficulté pour faire face
à cette crise qui a contraint bien des
nations y compris celle de la gambie à
recourir à des mesures inhabituelles en
nécessitant un niveau de ressources
extrêmement élevé et variées nous
reconnaissons toutefois que nos efforts
ont véritablement été appuyée grâce à
l'appui de grâce au soutien de nos
offres amis et partenaires
internationaux tels que l'onu la banque
mondiale le fonds monétaire
international l'union européenne et nos
partenaires bilatéraux
c'est la preuve de l'importance et de la
pertinence de la coopération
internationale ainsi que de la
solidarité dans nos quête de solutions
aux enjeux internationaux
monsieur le président les petits états
et les états en développement gère avec
difficulté le fardeau de la dette tout
en tentant de développer leur économie
la flambée de la pandémie a fait reculer
nos acquis nos recettes sont faibles
alors que nos dépenses publiques sont
élevés c'est maintenant la norme
l'économie de la gambie s'est réduite à
2 % de son pib et continue de se
contracter
notre secteur touristique est un
employeur centrale est une source de
devises étrangères majeur et il a été
dévastée l'emploi du chômage pardon
augmente extrêmement rapidement
face à cette situation complexe mon
gouvernement avec l'appui de ses
partenaires a adopté des programmes de
protection sociale
ces programmes ont permis d'atténuer les
souffrances de notre population
toutefois ces interventions ne saurait
être durable sans un appui externe
la mise en oeuvre de notre plan national
de développement de 2018 à 2021 a été
hypothéquée par la pandémie
la décennie d'action des nations unies
pour la mise en oeuvre du programme à
l'horizon 2030 quant à elle a été sapée
par cette pandémie il est donc essentiel
et urgent d'accélérer la mise en oeuvre
de nos engagements internationaux au
sujet du financement du développement et
de l'accord de paris sur les changements
climatiques
monsieur le président les pays en
développement tels que la gambie devront
pouvoir compter sur des mécanismes
d'appui des plans de renflouement de la
part des nations unies et de la
communauté internationale
enfin de pouvoir se relever de ce déclin
économique étant donné cette situation
nous réitérons l'appel de l'union
africaine un allègement de la dette ou
une annulation de la dette un accès
amélioré aux financements internationale
à une réduction des coûts de transaction
des transferts de fonds ainsi qu'à une
solidarité et un partenariat
internationaux accrue nous espérons que
les circonstances et difficultés uniques
auxquels se heurtent les pays les moins
avancés et plus particulièrement les
pays en transition telle que la gambie
feront l'objet d'une attention bien
particulière monsieur le président
autre la reconstruction de nos économies
et il convient de reconstruire le
système de soins de santé affaiblie et
par le biais d'actions humanitaires
nous devons reconstruire séville et ses
foyers détruits
nous avons la possibilité d'organiser
une véritable refonte de nos systèmes
nationaux de santé et du système
international de santé des systèmes de
surveillance des maladies
ces derniers pour être mieux préparé à
faire face à de tels pandémie monsieur
le président nous saluons le rôle joué
par l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qui a guidé les mesures sanitaires au
niveau international cela étant dit la
gambie a besoin d'un appui
supplémentaire pour élaborer sa
stratégie et ses programmes de
relèvement pour l'après pandémie en tant
que pays en transition
la pandémie remet en question les acquis
que nous avons obtenus en termes de
restauration de la démocratie de
réconciliation et de consolidation de la
paix dans mon pays
j'aimerais toutefois assuré la
communauté internationale que nous
sommes engagés à mener à bien le
programme de transition avec l'appui du
fonds d'appui à la consolidation de la
paix la communauté internationale nous
chérissons cet appui indispensable
nous appelons à une poursuite de cette
assistance afin que nous puissions
continuer de renforcer notre démocratie
dans un environnement propice à cela
nous saluons les travailleurs de
première ligne la communauté
scientifique qui tente de sauver des
vies et de trouver un vaccin et un
traitement à la coved 19 nous espérons
que lorsqu'ils seront trouvés les
traitements seront accessibles pour tous
monsieur le président la pandémie a mis
en lumière et à exacerber la fracture
numérique dans le monde notamment pour
ce qui est de l'éducation des millions
de personnes à travers le monde
deux n'ont pas accès aux cours en ligne
et ce en raison d'une impossibilité
d'avoir accès à l'internet
l'accès au numérique et à l'internet est
un facteur déterminant du travail et de
l'éducation
grâce à des partenariats renforcés pour
la mise en oeuvre de l'aude et des
quatre les pays en développement doivent
pouvoir contribuer à combler cette une
fracture du numérique garantir l'égalité
des chances quant à l'accès à
l'information l'éducation de qualité et
le renforcement des compétences en
termes de thijs et monsieur le président
l'insécurité est encore un enjeu est une
menace majeure qui pèse sur les pays du
sahel
nous sommes les victimes d'attaqués
d'imprévus contre nos communautés de
data qu de masse contre des peuples
innocents ou d'attentats terroristes qui
déplace nos populations et entraînent
des souffrances et des crises indicible
nous saluons les efforts déployés par
l'onu l'union africaine la cedeao et les
autres partenaires internationaux afin
de garantir sécurité et développement
dans la région
l'exécution de la stratégie intégrée des
nations unies dans le sahel est
essentiel pour garantir une paix durable
dans la région
nous félicitons également la cedeao qui
contribuent à la pacification de la
région
monsieur le président nous souscrivons
aux partenariats onu union africaine sur
la paix et la sécurité en afrique
malgré ces difficultés le continent
africain contribuer au maintien de la
paix de la sécurité internationale et
mérite donc le soutien de la communauté
internationale et plus particulièrement
de l'onu j'aimerais assurer à cette
auguste organe que la gambie
on va continuer d'honorer ses
engagements au titre de l'initiative dû
secrétaire général action pour le
maintien de la paix monsieur le
président la communauté internationale
ne doit pas baisser les bras
quant à sa lutte pour restaurer la paix
et la stabilité au mali en somalie au
soudan du sud en république
centrafricaine et dans d'autres régions
troublées
j'estime que l'onu et les autres
organisations régionales devraient en
faire plus pour endiguer les activités
du terrorisme armées et des groupes
criminels qui plus est les efforts de
l'union africaine visant à faire taire
les armes sur le continent africain
mérite un appui international et ce pour
nous pour la paix et la stabilité du
continent africain monsieur le président
s'agissant du conflit israëlo
palestinien
nous appelons la communauté
internationale à tenir compte de
l'initiative arabe pour la paix et a
procédé à un dialogue de fond pacifique
au sujet d'une solution à deux états
monsieur le président nous souscrivons
aux travaux de la cour pénale
internationale
nous appelons les etats-unis à renoncer
aux sanctions imposées contre la cour et
ses représentants le respect de l'état
de droit et dans leur intérêt dans de
tous les états démocratiques de plus
nous réitérons notre intérêt au sujet de
la sphère transmise à la cpi sur le sort
de la population rohingya au myanmar
dans ce contexte nous espérons pouvoir
compter sur l'appui de l'organisation de
la coopération islamique et de nos
partenaires sincères pour que justice
soit rendue au myanmar
monsieur le président afin de promouvoir
des relations de bon voisinage et des
relations amicales entre les états nous
appelons à la normalisation des
relations entre cuba et les etats unis
dans la même veine nous souscrivons
pleinement à la politique d'une chine
unique et nous comptons sur une
coopération mutuellement bénéfique et
une coopération internationale efficace
avec la république populaire de chine
alors que nous célébrons le 75e
anniversaire de cette organisation
démocratique
il est paradoxal de constater que
l'afrique négocie encore sa
représentation au conseil de sécurité
alors que la plupart de l'ordre du jour
de ce dernier porte sur le continent
africain sans aucun doute faire entendre
la voix de l'afrique au conseil
permettra de renforcer la confiance et
la légitimité de ses décisions
monsieur le président nous vous faisons
part de notre appui infaillible
allocation de votre présidence à la
soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale des nations unies
nous comptons sur votre rôle de chef de
file en ces temps difficiles et
inhabituelle
nous remercions également très
sincèrement notre ami et notre frère le
professeur tidjane minois à mad band est
du nigeria ainsi que son excellente
équipe qui ont mené à bien la présidence
précédente
en guise de conclusion je souhaite à
tous les états membres
un très heureux 75e anniversaire merci
ils n'ont blé au nom de l'assemblée
générale je remercie le président de la
république de gambie pour l'allocution
qu'il vient de prononcer je donne la
parole à la délégation du gabon pour la
présentation de l'allocution du chef
d'état sur le président
j'ai l'honneur d'introduire la
déclaration prix enregistrée de son
excellence ali bongo ondimba président
de la république gabonaise chef de
l'état dans le cadre du débat général de
la 64e session de l'assemblée générale
des nations unies
mais ce président majesté mesdames et
messieurs les chefs d'état et de
gouvernement mesdames et messieurs les
chefs de délégation monsieur le
secrétaire général mesdames et messieurs
monsieur le président permettez moi à
l'antenne de mon propos nous vous
adresser mes vives félicitations pour
votre brillante élection à la présidence
de cette 75e session l'assemblée
générale des nations unies j'y vois un
témoignage éloquent du rayonnement de la
diplomatie de votre pays est la
traduction de sa haute considération par
la communauté internationale je puis
vous assurer du plein soutien du gabon
tout au long de vos demandes à je
voudrais saluer le travail accompli par
votre prédécesseur le professeur tidjani
mohamed banner qui dans un comté
sanitaire particulièrement difficile a
su mobiliser les efforts de nos états
afin de conduire notre agenda s'exprime
également tout mon appréciation au
secrétaire général monsieur antonio
guterres est ce pour l'emploi du travail
réalisé dans le renforcement de
l'efficacité de notre organisation pour
son engagement à mettre en oeuvre les
courageux un fonds structurels que l'onu
est amorcée mais ce président le monde
est aujourd'hui un tournant de son
histoire
nous sommes en effet en plein milieu
d'une crise sanitaire sans précédent qui
déstructure nos sociétés et dans le
bilan affecte chaque nation en effet la
pandémie de la pro b business a
contribué à amplifier du défi politique
sécuritaire socio économiques auxquels
nos états sont régulièrement confrontés
aussi
devions-nous tirer les enseignements de
cette crise multiforme d'emblée l'un des
constats qui s'impose à nous et notre
interdépendance face à toute menace
contre la chaîne de l'humanité dont nous
sommes tous des maillots cela nous
rappelle que la seule voie de salut et
le multilatéralisme et plus de
solidarité internationale
c'est à l'aune de cette réalité que les
pères fondateurs de notre organisation
ont bâti le socle conceptuel de la
sécurité collective qui est au coeur de
la charte des nations unies
un autre évidence qui se dégage de ce
contexte de crise et l'insuffisance de
cadres normatifs pour faire face aux
défis globaux qui se posent à notre
monde aussi
devrions-nous nous réinventer et agir
plus efficacement pour contenir les
menaces transnationales et
transfrontalière à l'instar de la
pandémie actuelle au moment où le
concert des nations célèbrent les 75 ans
d'existence de l'onu notre maison
commune
nous devons être à la hauteur des
valeurs et des idéaux qui ont guidé sa
création
c'est le lieu de se féliciter de
l'importante déclaration adoptée à
l'occasion de la commémoration du 75e
anniversaire de l'onu celle-ci référé
significativement l'ampleur de la tâche
qui nous incombe est à la mesure des
engagements à prendre et des actions à
entreprendre afin que personne ne soit
laissé en marge
monsieur le président la thématique de
nos travaux et d'une portée
particulièrement pertinentes et
opportunes
en effet l'avenir que nous voulons l'onu
qu'il nous faut réaffirmant notre
attachement au multilatéralisme sont des
termes forts qui interpelle nos
consciences respectives en effet une
nation prise individuellement ne saurait
se mettre à l'abri du dérèglement
climatique
les temps sont liées à la concurrence
des échanges commerciaux à la montée des
inégalités à la multiplication des
attentats terroristes et des actes de
criminalité transnationale le monde dans
lequel nous vivons a besoin d'un système
multilatéral qui impulsent une
coopération au bénéfice de tous et à une
mutualisation de nos efforts à cet égard
la réforme du conseil de sécurité de
l'onu qui intègre une représentation
équitable en son sein et une
amélioration de ses méthodes de travail
se révèle comme une nécessité voire une
exigence le gabon par ma voix reste
fondamentalement attaché à la position
commune africaine telle qu'exprimée par
le consensus des opprimés et la
déclaration de syrte
parallèlement à plus de solidarité
internationale et est la réforme
attendue du conseil de sécurité de l'onu
la revitalisation des travaux de
l'assemblée générale ainsi que la
réforme du conseil économique et social
de l'onu doivent également être menées
en vue d'impulser une dynamique nouvelle
à notre organisation
monsieur le président à une nation unie
qu'il nous faut sont également
tributaires d'une redéfinition des
missions assignées aux institutions de
bretton woods ainsi
afin d'en faire de véritables moteurs du
développement et de la croissance
mondiale ces réformes sont
indispensables à l'émergence d'un ordre
international plus juste
prônant au mieux les intérêts de tous
car elles impactent la réalisation de
plusieurs objectifs de développement
durable à l'horizon 2030
y compris la réponse aux légitimes
aspirations des peuples africains
contenus dans l'agenda de 1103 monsieur
président hu nations unies ont tout
naturellement vocation à être une
réponse et peuple face aux menaces à nos
aspirations de dignité de paix et de
prospérité
une nation unies doivent être ainsi la
réponse l'humanité contre la fatalité et
l'injustice
les dix ans d'action pour une suite pour
un système multilatéral plus juste et
plus équitable a pour corollaire la
nécessaire stabilisation des coûts des
matières premières qui sont soumises à
une spéculation excessive
celle ci est source d'instabilité
difficilement compatible avec la
prévisibilité des ressources
mobilisables dont nos pays ont tant
besoin pour la réalisation de leurs
objectifs de développement dans la même
dynamique
une justice plus équitable consisterait
sans doute à rétribuer les pays qui
disposent de matières premières le juste
prix de leurs ressources naturelles
avenir que nous voulons exigent
également le respect des engagements
souscrits
c'est le lieu pour moi de rappeler
l'urgence de concrétiser ses engagements
pris en faveur des pays en développement
que ce soit en matière de transfert de
technologies propres et d'amélioration
de l'accès des peuples à l'énergie
renouvelable
il s'agit pour nous d'accélérer
leur passage d'une industrie est
traditionnel à consonance polluantes à
un industrie décarbonés respectueuse de
l'environnement pour le gabon celui ci
repose résolument sur un socle constitué
de trois piliers l'amélioration du cadre
de vie la mise en oeuvre des projets
d'adaptation au changement climatique et
la préservation de la biodiversité
le président au développement ne saurait
être durable sans paix ni sécurité
sensibilité malheureusement ces
fondamentaux continuent à être mise à
mal dans plusieurs régions du monde
les attaques terroristes récurrentes
nous révèle qu'aucune nation n'est à
l'abri de cette menace pour laquelle
notre réponse doit être fondée sur une
franche coopération à l'échelle locale
nationale régionale et globale
bien évidemment le gabon par m'envoie
solidaire de la communauté
internationale condamne le terrorisme
sous toutes ses formes d'une
manifestation et apporte son soutien aux
pays et aux peuples qui en sont victimes
monsieur le président le prix de
l'instabilité conjuguée aux effets du
terrorisme des foyers des tensions et
des déstabilisations multiforme est
particulièrement lourd pour de nombreux
pays africains
en effet il se trouve contraint de
consacrer d'importants de ressources à
ces phénomènes entretenue entre autres
par le commerce illicite des armes
légères et de petit calibre et de trafic
des espèces de faune et de flore
sauvages il est évident pour moi que
dans le combat contre ces sources
d'instabilité et de fragilité dans
plusieurs régions de notre continent
une approche globale et solidaire
11 car toute menace contre une nation
constitue tout naturellement une menace
contre tous à cet égard nous demeurons
résolument engagé aux côtés des nations
unies de l'union africaine comme au sein
de la communauté économique des états de
l'afrique centrale ceeac à un vrai à la
promotion de la stabilité de la paix
dans nos états mais ce président au plan
régional
j'ai reçu de mes pairs le mandat de
conduire la réforme institutionnelle de
la ceeac en vue de rendre notre
communauté plus efficiente afin qu'ils
révèlent les défis pour lesquels elle a
été créée notamment ceux relatifs à
l'intégration régionale et au
développement
le 26 juillet 2020 la conférence des
chefs d'état et de gouvernement de la
ceeac adopté une nouvelle nomenclature
organique plus dynamique et plus
opérationnels en vue de répondre aux
défis majeurs de l'heure notamment la
paix la sécurité et le développement
à cet effet le traité révisé de la ceeac
est entrée en vigueur le 28 août 2020 et
la commission de la ceeac nouvel organe
exécutif de notre organisation
communautaire a été mis en place le 31
août 2020 à l'issue de la prestation de
serment
l'ensemble de ses membres lors de son
17e sommet ordinaire la ceeac également
procédé à l'adoption d'un plan d'action
communautaire polar mise en oeuvre de la
résolution de la résolution 13,5 des
nations unies de la stratégie
communautaire en matière de réponse à la
cobi 19
elle a aussi procéder à l'harmonisation
des règles relatives aux
télécommunications aux technologies de
l'information et de la communication
un cyber sécurité et à l'interconnexion
transfrontalière monsieur le président
au plan national le gabon à l'instar de
nombreux pays a subi l'impact de la
baisse drastique des cours des matières
premières
accentuée par les effets la pandémie de
la comédie 9 une situation qui a conduit
au ralentissement de son activité
économique
dans ce contexte mon pays à poursuivre
les réformes engagées pour résorber les
déséquilibres à travers des mesures de
relance qui consacre l'ajustement
budgétaire
le développement des infrastructures et
la promotion du secteur privé comme
levier de la diversification et de la
transformation de notre économie
aujourd'hui nous pouvons nous réjouir
des signaux en croit jean qui se dégage
de la mise en oeuvre du plan de notre
plan de relance de l'économie
en effet grâce au retour de la
croissance impulsée par ses réformes le
gabon retrouve progressivement ne marche
pas neuve
celles ci sont nécessaires au
financement des investissements les plus
urgents notamment en matière de santé
d'éducation de formation d'emploi et
d'un futur
mais ce président l'inclusion est une
préoccupation majeur dans l'orientation
politique de mon pays c'est toute la
portée du programme politique pour
l'égalité des chances que j'ai un peu ce
en faveur d'un développement plus juste
plus équitable en valorisant les femmes
les jeunes les personnes les plus
vulnérables afin que personne ne soit
laissé en marge du développement de mon
pays
c'est dans cet élan qui m'a été donné de
nommé récemment une femme aux fonctions
de premier ministre chef du gouvernement
ainsi trois dames de grande valeur parmi
de nombreuses femmes de qualité occupe
désormais de très hautes fonctions au
sommet de l'état
c'est notamment le cas à la cour
constitutionnelle au sénat ainsi qu'à la
primature elles sont d'un apport
inestimable à la consolidation de nos
acquis démocratiques et notre marche
vers le peuple
monsieur le président l'avenir que nous
voulons et l'onu qu'il nous faut un
seront des voeux pieux tant que de
nombreux peuples et des êtres humains
demeurons en proie au fado de sang sont
iniques et souvent j saint-just je
voudrais à cet égard réitéré l'appel
solennel pour la levée totale de
l'embargo qui frappe cuba depuis
plusieurs décennies pour permettre à ce
pays de réaliser les objectifs de
développement durable
je ne saurais clore mon propos sans
réaffirmer l'attachement du gabon au
multilatéralisme se voit dans notre
légitime quête d'un avenir en confiance
et dans notre ambition commune de bâtir
une organisation qui fera face aux
enjeux complexes du développement
durable en définitive une organisation
qui trouve les solutions appropriées et
pérenne aux défis et menaces qui se
posent à l'humanité je vous remercie
le nombre et la zambie au nom de
l'assemblée générale je remercie le
président de la république du gabon pour
l'allocution qu'il vient de prononcer je
donne la parole à la délégation de la
libye pour qu'ils nous présentent
allocution du chef d'état cdh raïs ali
laminé zène monsieur le président
excellence monsieur le secrétaire
général mesdames et messieurs avant
d'introduire l'allocution de la libye
qu'il me soit permis de confirmer une
fois de plus que nous continuons de
soutenir toutes les initiatives et tous
les efforts qui visent à une résolution
pacifique de la situation en libye
comme chacun a pu le voir nous avons été
des pionniers dans notre appel au
dialogue et au cessez le feu
malgré notre situation nous avons essayé
de resserrer nos rangs nous nous sommes
félicités de l'initiative de plusieurs
étapes nous avons trouvé étrange que
certains continuent d'utiliser un
langage menaçant et de créer des lignes
rouges artificielle sur notre territoire
ce qui constitue une provocation directe
pour les libyens nous récusons toutes
ces menaces et toute menace d' ingérence
nous soulignons qu'une telle approche ne
pourrait conduire qu'à l'aggravation des
tensions une escalade de celle ci une
fois de plus nous appelons les états
concernés à faire preuve de sagesse et
de raison et à contenir les coupables de
la violation de cessez le feu qui sont
les véritables menaces pour la paix la
sécurité la stabilité régionale une
telle conduite sabotage toutes les
initiatives de paix que nous accueillons
monsieur le président j'ai l'honneur
d'introduire le message préenregistré du
président du conseil présidentiel du
gouvernement d'entente nationale
monsieur fayez mustapha serrage monsieur
le président excellences mesdames et
messieurs que la paix de dieu soit avec
vous monsieur le président je suis très
heureux à l'entâme de mon propos de vous
féliciter et votre pays frère pour votre
élection à la présidence de la soixante
quinzième session de l'assemblée
générale
nous vous souhaitons plein succès dans
ses fonctions et vous pouvez compter sur
le plein soutien de notre délégation qui
coopérera avec vous afin d'atteindre les
objectifs de cette session je remercie
également votre prédécesseur moi ma
tijani ben day pour les efforts qu'il a
consentis pendant la session précédente
je ne manquerai pas non plus de
souligner des efforts sans relâche de
secrétaire général monsieur antonio
guterres esch qui s'efforcent
de réaliser les buts et principes des
nations unies malheureusement cette
session se tient dans des circonstances
difficiles et cruelle liés à la con vite
19 qui ne connaît aucune frontière
géographique et qui ne fait pas la
différence entre les peuples la pandémie
continue de semer la mort et menace la
performance de tous les pays y compris
les pays qui souffrent d'instabilité et
de conflits comme le secrétaire général
l'a souligné à de nombreuses reprises
il n'est pas possible de combattre le
virus si ce n'est à travers la
solidarité une coopération plus forte et
un effort commun pour surmonter la
pandémie mesdames et messieurs à chaque
fois que j'ai l'occasion de m'adresser à
votre assemblée
j'aimerais pouvoir vous dire que nous
sommes arrivés au terme de la transition
difficile de mon pays j'aimerais pouvoir
vous dire que nous avons surmonté des
défis difficiles et que nous sommes
engagés sur la voie de la construction
d'un état démocratique avec une
passation de pouvoir
paisible où l'état de droit les droits
de la personne et la dignité humaine
sont protégés malheureusement certains
s'efforcent de saper ses aspirations
auquel libyens ont tant sacrifié
il insiste pour utiliser tous les moyens
qu'il soit même les moyens de plus
injuste et destructeur pour saisir le
pouvoir par la force mais nous ne
fléchit sont pas dans notre résolution
pour atteindre les objectifs pour
lesquels les martyrs ont donné leur vie
ces héros de notre armée nous ont prouvé
qu'ils sont le rock qui sera capable de
tenir en échec tous ceux qui essaieront
d'imposer la dictature dans notre pays
nous avons tenu notre promesse lorsque
nous avons dit que les envahisseurs
n'entrerai pas à tripoli en avril de
l'année dernière
la ville a tenu bon face à des attaques
tyrannique mené par les agresseurs et
par les milices qui les soutiennent les
dommages humains et matériels sont trop
un calcul incalculables pour les énoncés
ici des héros se sont sacrifiés pendant
l'initiative aux volcans de paix et nous
avons pu ainsi repousser cette agression
malheureusement cette agression
bénéficié du soutien de mercenaires et
d'un soutien matériel deux pays
donc chacun connaît et qui sont
d'ailleurs évoqué dans les rapports des
nations unies c'est inacceptable cela
constitue une violation de la
souveraineté de l'indépendance libyenne
ainsi que des résolutions du conseil de
sécurité et du droit international qui
interdisent l'ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures des états ne fait
aucun doute qu'une telle conduite ne pas
être comparés aux accords légitimes
conclut par les autorités légitimes avec
certains états alors que la situation
évolue et que le peuple les biens
enregistre des victoires peuple libyen
qui est déterminé à avancer à surmonter
tous les obstacles
nous appelons les états concernés à
revoir leur position et à ne plus faire
le pari des agresseurs mais plutôt de
s'asseoir à la table de négociations
avec le gouvernement dans prom nationale
pour essayer de trouver une solution à
leurs préoccupations
nous devons travailler à nouer des liens
fondés sur le respect mutuel les
intérêts communs et le principe de non
ingérence dans les affaires intérieures
nous avons saisi toutes les occasions
possibles pour réitérer notre engagement
envers les moyens pacifiques le dialogue
pacifique et constructif qui est le seul
moyen de sortir de l'impasse
nous travaillons de façon constructive
avec les nations unies et le processus
de paix et nous essayons de soutenir les
efforts des nations unies par tous les
moyens
nous travaillons de bonne foi dans le
cadre d'initiatives pour trouver des
solutions aux conflits récemment il y a
bien sûr la conférence de berlin qui
s'est terminée récemment nous avons
lancée nous mêmes un certain nombre
d'initiatives visant à résoudre la crise
politique et de sécurité et à un
résoudre les défis du quotidien de la
population libyenne
nous prouvons constamment que nous
voulons la paix non pas la guerre même
si nous sommes dotés de la force de la
foi nécessaire pour résister à
l'agresseur et pour le vaincre nous
voulons éviter l'effusion de sang afin
d'unifier les efforts pour combattre la
cog hill 19 qui menacent notre
population nous avons annoncé un cessez
le feu le 21 août et nous avons appelé à
des élections d'ici mars année prochaine
nous avons souligné qu'un cessez le feu
durable et véritable nécessite que les
régions de chauffera et de syrte soit
débarrassé d'armes des milices
étrangères et des forces étrangères qui
doivent se retirer du territoire libyen
voilà comment nous pourrons garantir la
souveraineté nationale sur la totalité
du territoire les biens 7,1 droit du
gouvernement d'entente nationale de nous
félicitons du soutien très large dos
bénéficie cette initiative et nous
espérons que des mesures pratiques
pourront rapidement être appliquées nous
espérons que l'autre partie acceptera
cela et se retirera des régions
mentionnées les milices doit retourner
dans leur pays et les champs pétroliers
et les ports doivent pouvoir rouvrir
il avait été fermé à cause d' influence
extérieure avec des pertes estimées à 9
milliards de dollars qui viennent
s'ajouter à des dommages graves causés
aux infrastructures
nous nous sommes félicités de la
déclaration des leaders politiques à
l'est de la libye qui ont appelé un
cessez-le-feu et à une reprise de la
production pétrolière
cependant la coopération de la part des
groupes armés et milices agresseurs
restent encore à établir
nous tenons ces groupes responsables
toute confrontation militaire et de
toute victime ou destruction qui serait
causée par ces agressions
mesdames et messieurs nous nous
efforçons sincèrement d'améliorer la vie
des libyens d'améliorer nos performances
de limiter la prolifération des armes et
de l'insécurité souvent à travers une
coopération avec la mission d'appui des
nations unies en libye des progrès
tangibles ont été faits mais ces efforts
ne sont pas viables à cause des
interventions extérieures et de la
division de nos institutions ainsi que
l'absence de production de pétrole qui
elle notre source de revenus principale
nous avons toujours su que surmonter
tous ces défis reposait dans la
formulation de politiques par un élu un
gouvernement élu d'entente nationale
c'est pourquoi nous réitérons notre
appel à un accord sur des fondements
constitutionnelle et l'organisation
d'élections présidentielle et
législatives
nous espérons pouvoir compter sur un
soutien fort de la communauté
internationale nous comptons également
sur la contribution des nations unies
qui doit fournir les conditions
nécessaires à des élections réussies des
élections que les libyens attendent
depuis trop longtemps de telles
élections mettre un terme à la crise de
légitimité pour atteindre cet objectif
nous estimons qu'il est nécessaire de
reprendre le dialogue politique et
d'impliquer tous les acteurs sur le
terrain toutes les factions et partis
politiques toutes les régions tous les
secteurs de la société quelle que soit
leur affiliation ou leur idéologie
la seule exception étant toute personne
dont les crimes ont été prouvés
juridiquement et qui ont causé des
effusions de sang libyen
mesdames et messieurs nous réaffirmons
notre engagement en faveur de la
promotion de la protection des droits de
la personne et à cette fin nous avons
adopté un certain nombre de lois
malgré les défis que nous connaissons
nous essayons de nous conformer aux
obligations internationales
à cet égard nous examinons actuellement
la possibilité d'accéder à davantage de
traiter de conventions de promotion des
droits de la personne
nous attachons également de l'importance
à la promotion des droits des femmes et
des
étaient entre les sexes et nous
continuons de fournir un accès gratuit à
l'éducation à la santé à tous nos
citoyens
les agressions contre tripoli
constituait une violation grave des
droits de la personne à cause des
pilonnages destruction assassinat
déplacement utilisation de mines
exécution et tout cela a testé par la
découverte de charny en dehors de
tarouma après la fin de cette attaque
toutes ces violations graves mérite une
réponse du conseil des droits de l'homme
à notre demande le conseil a formé une
commission denquête mesures dont nous
nous félicitons et nous nous disons prêt
à coopérer à faciliter le travail de
cette commission
nous appelons également la commission à
enquêter sur les violations commises
contre les citoyens à syrte par les
milices du général haftar dernièrement
un homme a été arrêté et exécuté devant
les yeux sous les yeux même de sa
famille le gouvernement d'entente
nationale est déterminé à protéger le
droit d'expression de ses citoyens un
droit consacré par la loi
nous devons leur donner la possibilité
d'exprimer leurs demandes légitimes de
conditions d'existence meilleur de
meilleurs services et une faim la
corruption
nous n'autoriserons pas que ce droit
soit foulé aux pieds
mesdames et messieurs une fois de plus
nous condamnons le terrorisme sous
toutes ses formes et nous soulignons que
ce phénomène ne doit pas être imputée à
quelques religion ou fois que ce soit
mon pays a consenti de grands sacrifices
pour éliminer les organisations
terroristes et un certain nombre de
combattants touristes étrangers dont des
shows qui venait de l'externe de la
libye qui menaçait non seulement notre
sécurité notre stabilité mais également
nos ressources naturelles des shows qui
essayait d'utiliser nos ressources pour
à partir de notre territoire mener des
opérations néfastes nous avons ratifié
toutes les conventions contre le
terrorisme et nous considérons que la
stratégie antiterroriste mondiale des
nations unies et ses quatre piliers
comme le cadre juridique le plus
important pour faciliter les efforts de
lutte contre le terrorisme à travers la
législation nationale la promotion de la
coopération régionale et internationale
cela reste le meilleur moyen pour
traquer les réseaux terroristes et les
éliminer je dois à cet égard mentionné
la nécessité de soutenir des programmes
régionaux et intra régionaux parmi
lesquels la coopération de la libye avec
certains des pays voisins
des opérations de contrôle des
frontières en conjointe pour pouvoir
arrêter les terroristes
mesdames et messieurs mon pays continue
d'apports d'actifs des de l'importance
au phénomène des migrations irrégulières
nous continuons de gérer les flux
importants de migrants qui s'expose au
danger des trafics illicites d'êtres
humains nous avons tiré la sonnette
d'alarmé auprès de la communauté
internationale
un problème que jusqu'à aujourd'hui
personne n'a réussi à résoudre en tant
que pays de transit la libye connaît des
conséquences de sécurité socio
économique très forte à cause de ce
phénomène qui a exacerbé notre
instabilité a eu une incidence négative
sur notre société
il est difficile de traiter en selle un
sujet sans une aide extérieure qui soit
à la hauteur du défi
nous espérons davantage de consultations
avec les organisations internationales
avec lesquels nous travaillons pour
atteindre pour plus d'obtenir une
connaissance plus fidèle de la situation
des migrants en libye
nous ne pensons pas que des informations
exagérées ou inexactes soit d'une grande
aide pour résoudre la situation ces
rapports ne sont pas d'une grande aide
puisque il met à l'index les autorités
du pays sans mentionner les eaux fort de
ces autorités de défendre les intérêts
des migrants ces rapports néglige le
fait que 100 cent mille migrants
irréguliers vivent de façon paisible
parmi des citoyens libyens travaille
dans différents secteurs et envoie des
fonds dans leur pays d'origine à leurs
familles
actuellement la communauté
internationale est d'accord sur le fait
que
le phénomène migratoire a plus important
que les capacités de quelques pays que
ce soit la libye est plus grande que
l'immigration ce n'est pas notre raison
d'être nous réitérons que la solution
idéale serait de travailler sur les
causes profondes des migrations la
communauté internationale doit aider les
pays d'origine et les encourager à
appliquer des programmes de
développement efficace et à améliorer la
performance de leur économie
davantage doit être fait pour faire
reculer la pauvreté le chômage et tout
les problèmes qui y poussent les gens à
se lancer dans un voyage pourtant
tellement dangereux mesdames et
messieurs mon pays accorde une grande
importance au désarmement et au maintien
de la paix de la sécurité
j'en veux pour preuve notre
participation active aux discussions sur
ce point et le fait qu'une solution
porter coauteur de nombreuses
résolutions sur ce sujet nous continuons
de respecter tous les traités et
conventions pertinents nous comprenons
que la production et le stock d'armes de
destruction massive et une menace pour
la sécurité internationale est une
source de préoccupation pour toute
l'humanité
nous participons également aux efforts
de désarmement pour les armes de
destruction massive et pour le maintien
de la paix de la sécurité
internationales
monsieur le président cela fait cinq ans
que nous avons commencé à appliquer des
objectifs de développement durable
il est préoccupant de constater que la
copie de 19 hypothèque que les progrès
accomplis jusqu'ici et entrave
l'application du programme en libye nous
continuons d'être en butte à des
difficultés importantes pour réaliser
ces objectifs parmi lesquels
l'instabilité politique dans notre pays
chacun sait qu'il ne saurait y avoir de
développement sans sécurité et pas de
sécurité sans développement
nous espérons pouvoir surmonter ses
difficultés pour pouvoir appliquer nos
programmes de développement 1 pour
pouvoir réaliser les audits et la
mobilisation des ressources nationales
est nécessaire
beaucoup des fonds de la libye ont fui
le pays et c'est pourquoi nous appelons
aux états vers lesquelles ces fonds ont
été détournés à nous aider à les
récupérer
nous aimerions à cet égard faire
allusion au fonds et biens gelés du
fonds souverain libyen gelé depuis 2011
à cause des sanctions du conseil de
sécurité
nous insistons sur le fait que le but de
ces sanctions est de protéger les biens
et les fonds libyens et non pas
continuer de les diminuer en fait ce qui
se passe dans la réalité c'est que nous
enregistrons de grandes pertes à cause
du gel de ses avoirs
nous avons donné au conseil de sécurité
des données depuis mars 2016 sur les
pertes que nous avons subies nous avons
demandé un amendement du régime de
sanctions malheureusement nous n'avons
pas obtenu de réponse à cette demande
légitime
monsieur le président ma délégation
soutient les uns réforme
emmenée par le secrétaire général des
nations unies malgré les progrès
accomplis
l'organe le plus important de
l'organisation le conseil de sécurité
n'a toujours pas été réformé or il est
important de réformer ce conseil qui ne
reflète plus les équilibres du 21e
siècle
la situation géopolitique nous impose
une réforme du conseil pour une
représentation plus équitable
nous soutenons la proposition vision à
corriger l'injustice historique faite à
l'afrique en lui accordant les sièges
proposés dans le consensus d oloumi et
dans la déclaration de syrte
c'est à dire deux sièges permanents avec
tous les droits qui y sont associés et
cinq sièges non permanents
supplémentaires
ça te demande constitue un minimum pour
corriger l'injustice infligée à notre
continent
à cet égard nous soutenons la demande
présentée par le groupe arabe en vue
d'obtenir un siège au conseil
mesdames et messieurs la paix au
moyen-orient ne pourra pas être réalisés
tant que des puissances occupantes
continueront d'occuper le territoire
palestinien et continueront de créer des
colonies et menaceront de mesures de
blocus supplémentaires les résolutions
sur cette question continue d'être
méprisés alors nous nous rallions
palestiniens qui rejettent les pratiques
de la puissance occupante
nous demandons avec eux la création d'un
état indépendant avec jérusalem pour
capitale
nous rejetons également toute tentative
de détourner la question palestinienne
pour servir d'autres intérêts sans
consulter les palestiniens eux mêmes
nous continuerons de soutenir l'idéal
d'un état palestinien pour conclure
j'aimerais souligner qu'un état
démocratique et l'aspiration qui a
poussé les libyens à se battre c'est ce
que nous souhaitons en libye nous
aspirons à vivre dans un état où le
pouvoir puisse être transmis de façon
paisible où les droits soient respectés
et où la primauté du droit soit acquise
un état qui vivent dans la paix qui se
développe qui coopèrent avec ses voisins
qui renonce à l'extrémisme et au
terrorisme
la libye possède les capacités
nécessaires pour réaliser cette
aspiration
les libyens sont capables avec la
coopération et l'aide de leurs amis de
bâtir un avenir prospère
nous espérons que nous pourrons
rapidement mettre un terme à la phase
actuelle extrêmement douloureuse et
pouvoir transformer la libye en un état
démocratique plurielle qui respecte la
diversité culturelle
ainsi que la primauté du droit merci
monsieur le président au nom de
l'assemblée générale je remercie le
président du conseil de la présidence du
gouvernement d'entente nationale de la
libye pour l'allocution qu'il vient de
prononcer je donne maintenant la parole
à la délégation de chypre pour
l'introduction de l'allocution du chef
d'état est en dessous du monsieur le
président j'ai l'honneur de vous
présenter l'allocution de son excellence
monsieur nikos anastasia deiss président
de la république de chypre merci elle
telle mesure monsieur le président
excellences mesdames et messieurs
d'emblée j'aimerais remercier très
sincèrement le président de la soixante
quatorzième session de l'assemblée
générale monsieur more a man band et
nous saluons l'excellente façon dont il
s'est acquitté de son mandat pendant
cette période sans précédent de pandémie
à la coved 19 j'aimerais également
félicité le président nouvellement élu
de la soixante quinzième session de
l'assemblée générale monsieur volkan
boschi je lui souhaite plein succès à
l'occasion de son mandat dont il va
s'acquitter de façon juste et
transparente monsieur le président
excellences mesdames et messieurs la
république de chypre fait sienne le
thème choisi pour cette session phare du
75e anniversaire des nations unies c'est
un thème plus pertinent que jamais il
fait explicitement réfléchissez
référence à l'avenir que nous voulons
l'onu dont nous avons besoin et
réaffirmé notre engagement collectif en
faveur du multilatéralisme
nous sommes tous les témoins de tendance
à l'unilatéralisme ou de recrudescence
de discours nationaliste entraînant dans
les gîtes un déficit de légitimité
remettant en question la crédibilité et
sapant l'efficacité de l'organisation
dans le même temps nous sommes aussi
confrontés à des crises internationales
telles que la pandémie les conflits
civils à la migration forcée le
fondamentalisme religieux la faim la
pauvreté et l'extrémisme violent
la destruction du patrimoine culturel
soyons francs c'est pour toutes ces
raisons que l'on est déçu que l'on est
sceptique au sujet de l'efficacité du
multilatéralisme
alors que la population exprime sa
frustration face à des institutions
internationales
incapable ou ne souhaitant pas
s'acquitter de leur mandat ayant perdu
lien avec toute la réelle avec la
réalité
nous devons être à la hauteur de nos
responsabilités comme une grâce à ce
leadership collectif nous devons
réaffirmer notre engagement nous devons
restaurer les bases sous jacente du
multilatéralisme efficace la
responsabilité conjointe et meilleure
solidarité à cette fin le 75e
anniversaire des nations unies nous
offre la possibilité de voir notre
organisation retrouver le rôle qui lui
revient et revitaliser ces outils pour
faire valoir les valeurs universelles et
monsieur le président parmi eux pendant
cette époque extraordinaire
la pandémie a démontré la vulnérabilité
les points faibles du monde
la pandémie a confirmé que des efforts
concertés constitue le seul espoir de
notre humanité
et une nécessité indispensable comme le
dit ce que le secrétaire général avec
éloquence éviter la propagation de
lakovic 19 est une responsabilité
commune pour chacun d'entre nous nous
devons agir ensemble
aucun pays ne peut le faire à lui seul
tout comme ceux que j'ai déjà dit et je
dois le reconnaître moi même et nous
tous sommes véritablement préoccupé face
à cette tendance à la hausse
préoccupante de nouveaux cas et de décès
de coronavirus à travers le monde
voilà pourquoi la seule solution pour
protéger les pans les plus vulnérables
c'est de faire montre de solidarité en
aidant les pays dont les systèmes de
soins de santé ont besoin d'assistance
cette solidarité doit également prévoir
le partage d'un vaccin contre la coved
19 et ce de façon équitable est
réciproque
dès que ce vaccin existera monsieur le
président excellences mesdames et
messieurs afin d'être cohérent
étant donné ce que j'ai dit au sujet des
valdes au sujet des valeurs du
multilatéralisme et des enjeux auxquels
nous nous heurtons je vais m'appesantir
sur une région géographique bien
particulière se trouvant parmi elles les
plus complexes
le moyen-orient nous sommes tous
préoccupés par les interventions de la
turquie ces interventions des
répercussions sur l'intégrité
territoriale la stabilité de la libye de
la syrie et de l'irak
nous sommes tout aussi préoccupé par les
violations commises par ce pays à
l'encontre des droits souverains de la
grèce et de chypre
toutes ces actions ont donné lieu à des
conditions d' instabilité croissante
avec des répercussions néfastes non
seulement pour la région
mais pour le monde chypre même si est un
c'est un petit pays est à l'origine de
synergies nous sommes à l'origine de la
coopération nous faisant la promotion
d'un réseau de partenariats nous
établissons des systèmes trilatéraux
multilatéraux de coopération avec la
l'egypte la grèce le liban la jordanie
israël la palestine
l'arménie entre autres ces partenariats
sont fondés sur les principes du droit
international et des relations de bon
voisinage et ses partenariats ne sont
donc pas créés contre un pays tiers on
n'exclut pas de pays partageant notre
vision en faveur d'une paix durable et
de la stabilité de notre région
malheureusement étant donné la situation
et l'évolution positive des reprises de
relations entre israël et des pays
arabes
la terre et la turquie joue un jeu
systématique d'escaladé des tensions en
menant à bien des plans expansionnistes
en ayant recours à la force
je ne vais pas m'appesantir en long et
en large sur le comportement de la
turquie nous le connaissons tous dans
les pays susmentionnés je veux je vais
me concentrer sur les mesures
unilatérales que prend ce pays à
l'encontre du mien ne le besoin de vous
rappeler que chypre et sa population
sont encore les victimes de l'invasion
militaire illégale de 1974
ainsi que de l'occupation militaire de
37 % de notre pays et du déplacement
forcé de 4 40% de sa population depuis
lors et malgré un travail constructif de
moi-même et de mes prédécesseurs afin de
trouver une solution juste et viable en
cause de la position intransigeante et
des demandes et exigences irrationnel de
la turquie chypre est encore le dernier
pays européens divisés
les derniers efforts visant à aboutir à
une solution remonte à 2010 cette suite
à une initiative du secrétaire général
de l'onu
il s'agissait de convoquer une
conférence multilatérale sur chypre a
crânement tana lors de cette conférence
le secrétaire général avait identifié un
cadre en reprenant six éléments à
discuter de façon interdépendante et
globale y compris un chapitre sur la
sécurité des garanties afin de trouver
un accord stratégique jetant les bases
d'une solution globale
malheureusement malgré notre travail
positif et la présentation de
propositions écrites crédible et
réaliste
les négociations ont échoué en raison de
l'inflexibilité de la turquie turquie
qui a insisté à maintenir le traité de
garantie anachronique ainsi que son
droit d'intervention ou encore la
présence permanente de troupes turques
sur l'île il s'agit d'une approche qui
va à l'encontre de notre qualité d'état
membre de l'union européenne ainsi que
des interventions du secrétaire général
de l'onu du 4 juin 2010 cette suite à sa
rencontre avec les dirigeants des deux
communautés et je cite
les progrès 1 dans le chapitre de la
sécurité et des garanties constitue un
élément indispensable pour aboutir un
accord général et y construire la
confiance entre les deux communautés
quant à leur avenir
depuis lors et malgré notre déception
nous n'avons eu de cesse de faire part
de notre volonté de reprendre
directement des négociations pour
trouver une solution au problème
chypriote
là où nous en sommes restés à crans
montana
à ce sujet je me félicite de constater
que le secrétaire général a l'intention
de travailler personnellement à la
reprise des négociations après la fin
des procédures politiques internes au
sein de la communauté chypriote turque
de mon côté je répète notre point de vue
un flexible nous nous sommes engagés à
reprendre sans délai le processus de
paix conformément au consensus auquel
nous sommes parvenus avec le secrétaire
général et le responsable chypriote turc
que le 25 novembre 2019 stipulant les
principes de la reprise d'un nouveau
tour de négociations
dans le même temps et je suis très clair
là dessus
étant donné que c'est une condition
sinequanone de tout processus de paix
pour que les négociations reprennent et
qu'elle ait de véritables chances de
réussir il est essentiel de créer les
conditions propices à des négociations
de bonne foi constructive sur un pied
d'égalité et non dans des comptes dans
un contexte d'anti mutation et de
menaces
et j'ai insisté là dessus j'ai dit
qu'outre l'occupation constante de notre
pays par la turquie nous sommes les
témoins de toute une série de mesures de
provocation qui vont à l'encontre du
droit international à l'encontre des
résolutions pertinentes du conseil de
sécurité et de la convention de l'onu
sur le droit de la mer
il s'agit d'activités minières dans
notre zone économique exclusive ou
encore de menaces d'ouverture de la
ville de varrault chat se trouvant sous
contrôle militaire turque
je m'attendais monsieur le président
suite à l'intervention du secrétaire
général des nations unies après avoir
entendu sa volonté de reprendre les
négociation que la turquie répondrai par
la positive
cela étant nous déplorons la réaction de
la turquie qui par le truchement de son
ministre des affaires étrangères a dit
publiquement que sont sa volonté son
objectif était d'établir ou d'imposer
une solution à deux états où un système
confédéral de gouvernance
et je suis encore plus attristées suite
à l'intervention du président de la
turquie monsieur erdogan au débat
général des nations unies ce qui est
véritablement ou déplorable ce sont les
efforts futile de monsieur erdogan
d'aller à l'encontre de vérité
historique de créer des tensions et de
données et de laisser accroire que les
tensions au moyen-orient sont le fruit
d'actions unilatérales prises par les
grecs et les chypriotes grecs
jamais je ne m'étais attendue à ce qu'un
pays qui a été condamné à maintes
reprise par une kyrielle de résolution
de l'onu ou de décisions du conseil de
sécurité ainsi que de décisions de la
cour européenne des des droits de
l'homme en raison de son niveau de son
invasion et occupations illégales de 37
% de notre pays
prétendrait et je cite qu'au delà des
camps raison que les deux ce qui
sous-tend les tensions dans l'est de la
méditerranée
c'est l'attitude de certains pays
souhaitant tout emporté il ne rien
laisser aux autres
alors je me demande qui est ce pays qui
adoptent cette approche
quel pays préfèrent agir sa relation sur
la base du pouvoir de la puissance et
non sur la base des règles ce qui est
également un fallacieux
c'est que monsieur erdogan prétendent
qu'ils n'ont aucune aucun intérêt direct
ou légitime dans l'est de la
méditerranée ou dans d'autres régions
alors je me demande aussi quel pays a
occupé et envahi chypre quel pays a
envahi la syrie quel pays est intervenue
militairement en libye
quel pays viole les droits souverains de
la deux
res quel pays intervient sanger dans les
affaires intérieures de l'irak
mesdames et messieurs ce qui est encore
plus par paradoxal quant à la proche de
monsieur erdogan ce sont ces
commentaires il a dit nous ne pouvons
pas fermer les yeux sur les violations à
l'encontre de notre pays et des turcs
les chypriotes turcs et sur le fait que
nos intérêts sont ignorés et l'a à
nouveau je pose la question quel intérêt
sont ignorés lorsque la turquie prétend
limiter notre zone économique exclusive
de 44% et ce aux dépens des chypriotes
grecs et turcs
quel intérêt sont foulées aux pieds
lorsque la turquie choisi de mépriser
les accords conclus entre les dirigeants
des deux communautés tant en 2011 et
2015 qui stipule que entre autres je
cite chypre fédérale continuera d'être
parties contractantes à la convention de
l'onu sur le droit de la mer de 1982 et
que tout recettes émanant de
l'exploitation des ressources naturelles
de l'état reviendront au gouvernement
fédéral
et je rappelle que ces consensus n'ont
jamais été remis en question par la
turquie ou par le volet chypriotes turcs
et c'est pour la même raison que la
question des hydrocarbures n'a jamais
été soulevée lors d intenses
négociations entre 10 2011 à 2017
cela n'a pas non plus été mentionné dans
le cadre du secrétaire général présenté
à grône montana
dans le même temps la turquie
fait fi du fait que la république de
chypre a créé un fonds souverain
national qui préserve les intérêts des
chypriotes grecs et turcs pour toutes
les recettes émanant de l'exploitation
de gisements d'hydrocarbures
de plus la turquie refuse de reconnaître
ma proposition visant à établir un
compte pour le bénéfice de la communauté
chypriote turque sur lequel on verserait
les recettes de l'exploitation des
hydrocarbures en fonction de la
proportion de la population dans l'état
et si la turquie reconnaît les droits
souverains de la république de chypre
sur sa zone économique exclusive et bien
ses recettes devraient également être
utilisé pour le bien de la communauté
chypriote turque
même avant de trouver une solution au
problème de chypre
donc comme le pro le prouve tout ce que
j'ai dit les affirmations de la turquie
indiquant que ces mesures ont pour
objectif de protéger les chypriotes
turcs sont totalement infondées sont
contraires à la vérité tout comme les
affirmations selon lesquelles la
république de chypre violerait les
droits de la turquie
j'aimerais par contre me saluer d'une
intervention de monsieur erdogan je le
cite à nouveau
il a dit notre priorité est de régler
les différends
grâce à un dialogue sincère sur la base
du droit international et sur un pied
d'égalité
si monsieur erdogan souscrit
véritablement à ce qu'il a dit et s'il
est véritablement convaincu que les
actions de la turquie à l'encontre de la
république de chypre sont compatibles
avec le droit international pourquoi
n'accepte il pas notre proposition de
dialogue bilatéral sincère ou de
recourir à la cour internationale de
justice
chers amis le droit international ne
saurait être appliquée de façon
unilatérale
selon les caprices de certains ne
serait-il pas mieux et plus utile pour
nous tous de régler nos différends
conformément à la pratique du droit
international pour ma part j'aimerais
rappeler à nouveau que je suis prêt à me
lancer dans un dialogue constructif et
ou de respecter tout jugement de la cour
internationale
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs ce jeu visant à accuser a
montré du doigt est utilisé par ceux qui
sont responsables de l'absence de
solution ou parce qu'ils créent ces
difficultés
c'est très clairement ce qu'a fait
monsieur erdogan en nous accusant en
disant que la ce le seul obstacle à la
solution celle approche sans compromis
injuste injustifiable d'elle des
chypriotes grecs comme je l' ai déjà dit
on sait très bien qui de par son
invasion militaire et ses actions
illégales divise la république de chypre
myriad de résolution de l'onu des
décisions du conseil de sécurité ainsi
que les jugements de la cour européenne
des droits de l'homme parlent d'eux
mêmes et dans le même temps je me pose
les questions suivantes
est ce vraiment faire montre de
fermeture d'esprit que de vouloir
établir un état indépendant souverain
sans garantie étrangères son
intervention d'un pays étranger sans
présence de troupes étrangères
quels autres états membres des nations
unies doivent faire l'objet de garanties
de la part d'un état tiers n'est-il pas
injuste at il véritablement juste de
plaider pour la création d'un état
normal de pouvoir prendre ses décisions
soient même avec ses citoyens sans
intervention étrangère est ce que c'est
faire montre de fermeture d'esprit que
de vouloir créer un système robuste de
sécurité fondée sur la charte de l'onu
et les traités de l'union européenne et
du conseil de l'europe
les constitutions des états fédéraux ne
stipule t'elle pas que chaque décision
prise au niveau fédéral doit faire
l'objet d'un vote positif par au moins
un des membres constituant qu'en est il
lorsque de la situation lorsque ce
membre est contrôlé par un pays tiers
chers amis j'estime selon moi que les
colons turcs supplante maintenant le
nombre de chiffres et aux turcs et jeudi
que l'insistance de la turquie a
conservé un traité de garantie est un
droit d'intervention ainsi qu'il ne
présente permanente de troupes turques
va dans ce sens
si le président erdogan estime que ce
qu'il demande pour les chypriotes turcs
et justes et justifiées
pourquoi n'octroie t-il par les mêmes
droits aux kurdes étant donné que la
proportion de cette population est
similaire à la proportion de la
population chypriote turque
excellences mesdames et messieurs je
n'ai mentionné là que quelques exigences
préconditions mesures illégales prises
par la turquie à chypre
je ne vais pas m'appesantir sur d'autres
prétentions activités absurde ne
correspondent absolument pas à la
volonté d'aboutir à un accord efficace
et viable conformément au droit
international ou conforme à notre
qualité d'état membre de l'union
européenne ce que je vais me contenter
de répéter c'est que en tant que pays
européens et en respectant pleinement
les valeurs les principes de l'union
européenne et de l'onu
notre intention n'a jamais été et ne
sera jamais de priver nos compatriotes
chypriotes turcs de leurs droits
légitimes
conformément aux acquis de l'union
européenne et de la charte de l'onu
je suis convaincu et à condition qu'il
n'y ait pas d'ingérence de l'extérieur
qu'il existe des points de convergence
entre les deux communautés permettant
d'aboutir à un accord
concrétisant la volonté de notre
population à savoir vivre dans un pays
européen
véritablement indépendant et souverain
un pays à l'abri de troupes étrangères
de droits d'intervention avec des
conditions de stabilité permettant à un
avenir sûr prospère et pacifique une
solution il y aurait ni gagnant ni
perdant respectant pleinement les points
de vue et préoccupations des deux
communautés
un état véritablement dirigé par les
chypriotes
et non un état dirigés depuis l'étranger
nous avons bel et bien tourné la page de
la colonisation
excellences mesdames et messieurs en
guise de conclusion je répète à nouveau
que renforcer notre engagement en faveur
du multi râleurs multilatéralisme et de
la coopération internationale sous tendu
par la charte des nations unies est
essentiel pour appuyer les trois piliers
des nations unies la paix et la sécurité
le développement et les droits de la
personne
à cette fin j'aimerais me faire l'écho
d'une des citations les plus
encourageantes de notre dernière session
nous sommes unis dans notre humanité
commune
nous devons laisser à la paix sa chance
merci nombre il offre aux noms de
l'assemblée générale je remercie le
président de la république de chypre
pour l'allocution qu'il vient de
prononcer nous venons d'entendre le
dernier bord at her inscrit un débat
général pour cette séance
la neuvième séance plénière pour la
poursuite du débat général débutera à 15
heures avant de lever la séance
je rappelle aux membres les mesures de
sécurité notamment les mesures de
distance physique dans la salle et à ses
abords la séance est levée
thanks to one
next one
si john lennon thomas lee hee-won han
guan
artaud d'applis aussi toute une remontée
tout me and my baby one by one
next là aussi tout dort comme un bébé
autochtone crise
next aussi nous donnerons pas là autour
au meilleur prix
next comme si un lion taurine en pis
jackman crise
dans from tuvalu tout vietnam crise
jba premier ministre et des reprises
corinne afrique
rome 4 de chuck république
car équipes sont fabriqués cartonné à 10
from his wattignies tigana
fang liste de la liste grise
[Musique]